Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
You guys... you guys were in here, but we were leaking.
Leaks?
That's right.
That's why we were late a little bit too, because we were gossiping.
Oh my god.
We were talking about you behind your back.
Oh my god, and then they said...
You'll never know what we're talking about.
That's messed up.
Hey, it could be good things.
Right, Vin?
I said some good stuff about Chad.
I don't know about you, though.
Oh, yeah, they're totally gonna believe that.
They could... they're gonna be like...
That's my streamer, Ducky.
She always says good things about us.
I do!
You whiz!
I've never.
There's so many clips about...
About like, what is it?
She hates us.
Like, what's that, huh?
No, they're saying that in your chat, which means you hate them.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That came from your chat.
That came from you.
No, this is not my stream.
This is not my channel.
But you're here.
Everything...
Everything... So it like...
I don't know, I don't...
I don't take ownership of this.
Mints hate us.
What do you say Mint hates us?
No, Doki hates us.
No, I see Mint hate us.
Doki hates us.
Minto hates us and Doki's cat.
Jean says Minto loves us, and Hugh C says Doki hates us.
Okay, well, if I put a poll right now...
It would be 50-50.
Okay, okay.
Does Mint hate us?
No, no, no.
It's gotta be who hates us more, Doki and Mint.
That's too late.
You said it's 50-50.
Yes!
Oh, look at that!
Oh, it's 77!
I don't think 77...
Oh, wait, it's going down.
Make it 50-50, make it 50-50.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Make it 80%.
Make it 50-50.
Oh, it's 71% right now.
This is... This is...
You are... It's on your channel.
They're biased.
Of course, they're going to listen to you.
Thanks for the Akasupa.
For it to ask Mint something.
I mean...
Oh.
I appreciate it.
Oh, it's not my channel.
Oh, it's at 69.
No, stay at 69.
Nice.
69.
It's alright.
See?
Look, I knew it.
I was right.
I'm always right, guys.
I'm always right.
Okay, so today we are...
What?
I was dehydrating!
Uh-huh.
Today, um...
We are playing potentially the final chapter of Visage.
And, uh...
We are going to have a guide out.
We're not going to...
We're going to be transparent with all of you guys.
And that we're going to have a guide out.
Because we realize there's no...
There's not really a way to start chapter four.
Um...
Because we're trying to find things.
And what we're trying to find are, like, tapes or whatever.
And I'm pretty sure I do not have all the tapes that we're supposed to get.
So...
So we will need a guide for that.
Um...
Or we'll potentially never finish this game, which is something I do not want to go through.
This is the final arc in the minute.
I will never collab ever again.
This is...
Never again!
This is it!
This is the last time!
For Charity!
She only came back for Charity!
Yeah, you only came back for Charity.
What?
I'm still trying to find a walkthrough.
Hold on.
Wait, you still haven't found a guide yet?
No.
No!
The end of the contract.
Yeah, she signed a contract.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Okay.
When she had to do like...
Like, it was like six streams for 2025 and I already reached the quota.
I feel like we got most of these.
There's this one and probably this one.
Two.
I think there's two that we need to get.
Alright, there's two?
Okay, let me boot up the game.
Alright, so also I told...
Yeah, I didn't even...
I told Mint that I can't drink today.
You guys know I can't drink right now.
Because I am sick and I don't want to make it worse.
So, because I cannot drink, I might be a lot more scared and a lot more slow.
Oh, we got past all the scary stuff.
You don't know that?
You don't fucking know that?
Wait, literally went through the whole game?
What else is there?
Chapter four!
There's not gonna be anything scary.
What do you mean?
Okay, you don't even...
No, you're not even playing the game!
Um...
I heard they might...
I heard they might release Visage 2.
You should try it.
2?
Yeah!
No!
I don't know if my chat was memeing me, but they're like...
Oh, they don't know.
Chapter two might come out.
Is that actually true or people were just fucking with me?
They're...
They're messing with you.
Were they?
Oh yeah, they were.
I don't see anything.
I literally Googled Visage 2 and they're like...
You got one guide?
I got one guide.
Actually, I got two guides.
I ego-searched.
Two!
That's the worst.
You know that moment when you ego-search and...
And people were like, oh, Visage 2?
Yeah.
You were ego-searching and you found out?
Yeah, yeah.
I was, you know...
I was ego-searching myself on Twitter and I saw someone was like...
Oh man, she doesn't know there's a Visage 2.
So I got two guys.
Okay, you deserve that.
You deserve that actually.
You actively stalk your fans!
Don't...
No, I don't!
They show up!
They show up in my feed!
Because you keep stalking them!
So it triggers the algorithm!
Like, that's what it does!
You actively look up your fans' untag post that it now shows up on your algorithm.
It's not my fault that Twitter is so aggressive about it.
They...
It's called the algorithm for a reason!
Oh no!
She's obsessed with us!
Then...
No...
Clearly you guys say that I hate you because it's 73%.
Yeah, but like...
You know like those people who like hate them so much that they want that they hate watch?
You...
You hate stalk your fans!
I hate stalk!
Can you share the game?
Okay, I didn't even boot up the game yet.
Boot up the game!
She's stalling, everybody!
She's stalling!
I'm always stalling!
This is...
This is the whole reason...
We start the game like 20 minutes in every time.
Alright, let's see...
Guys, I have a guide!
And I'm the guide for today!
Okay, the last...
Before stream!
I told Doki, leave it to me!
I don't believe you!
Okay...
Alright...
Let's see...
Okay, we can...
You see the game feed?
Yeah, I see the game.
Alright, here we go.
This is the last time...
Guys, how's the volume?
Is it too quiet for her?
The game hasn't even started yet!
Turn it up all the way up.
We're literally loading in!
We're back in church, though.
Okay, guys, I need to know...
Wait, why am I here?
Where are you?
Wait, how did I get here?
How did I...
Wait...
You beat the game...
You beat it, right?
Oh, I remember how I got here.
Oh my god, to go back to the breaker room.
Wait...
Oh, that's right, the breaker.
Oh my god...
Well, you have to go to the basement anyway for one of the tapes.
Oh, fuck.
It's just a tape.
I don't know where the breaker room is!
Yes, you do!
You know where that is.
No, I don't!
Yes, you do!
It's by the TV...
All the way down the hallway.
That door at the very end.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Stupid fucking ghost.
Right there.
Stupid ghost.
Come on.
What are you saying stupid ghost for?
They're stupid.
They know they are.
What?
Wait, did I do it?
Oh, I did.
Okay.
I think so.
Alright, alright.
Before...
Okay, let me pause the game.
Already?
Okay.
What does the guide say?
You know the area that says the basement rules?
Yeah?
Yeah, go there.
It's in one of the drawers.
Wait, didn't we already get those videos?
I don't know.
I'm just...
That's one of the ones we might be missing.
Oh, I forgot.
I'm dual wielding.
Okay, so...
I can't remember.
What I need to know is if...
For the candles...
Like...
Right here.
In this little drawer thing.
On the second...
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so you already got that one.
Okay.
Okay, so I have one question.
It's for the candles.
So, like, for the candles...
Don't leave.
Don't leave it.
Yeah.
Like, do they...
Do they restore my sanity?
Yes, I think so.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
I'm...
I'm not okay.
Okay, so now you're gonna go into the boiler room.
I don't know if we got this one either.
That's the storage room.
I don't know where the fuck the boiler room is.
The boiler room is...
It's in a corridor behind the wall to the left of the TV is what it says.
What?
So, go to the TV.
Okay, let's go to the tapes and see what videos we're missing.
Like, I think that's...
So, we don't have to do it.
There's only...
Only two down here.
Just...
It's...
I think it's...
Wait, what?
Maybe the thing is busted.
Fucking...
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, I guess we'll go see what tapes are missing.
Turn around.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me turn on all the lights.
Let me...
Let me make sure all the lights are on.
So I don't...
There's a candle right there.
Is that not a candle?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Wait, I can just put...
Oh, I could just put it there.
Alright.
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, what are you doing?
Is it on?
I don't...
I don't know.
I'm trying to fucking put a candle on.
Do you know how candles work?
Oh my god, apparently I don't!
Okay, there you go.
I did it.
Candles, how does it work?
Okay.
Okay, I have one, two, three, four.
I have four.
Four?
Wait.
I have pride.
Did you change it?
There's a child there.
Look at this out.
Wait, you only have four?
Yeah.
Is that bad?
Okay, you have pride.
Do you have negligence?
Wait, let me drop this.
Okay, so...
Alright, there's...
There's that.
I'm watching the video.
I don't know.
We don't care about the video.
Oh, okay.
We care about the tape.
Wait, okay.
Um...
We have pride.
Alright, put it into the little slot on the left.
Store.
Oh.
Alright, so...
We have...
We have prison.
Pride.
Oh, prison.
Prison.
We have indifference.
We have addiction.
Okay.
And we have pride.
So...
We need greed, which was in the basement like I fucking told you.
Okay, we didn't know that because we got a video that I already have.
I did!
I didn't know!
Okay.
I did know!
No, you didn't.
Yes, I did.
That's why I told you to go to the trailer room!
Prove it!
Okay, and then what else do we have?
I go prove it because I know you haven't been in there!
No, you don't.
You don't even know where it was.
I told you!
It's in the boiler room!
Okay, what's the other video?
What's the other video?
I don't know where that boiler room is!
Okay, but like, what's the other video?
Um, the other one is in the progress room.
Okay, I'll grab that one first.
Oh wait, no, sorry.
Once you step out of the progress room, go down...
Oh wait, there's a cabinet across from the sofa.
Okay.
That I can do.
Yeah.
A cabinet across from the sofa.
Yeah, it says once you step out of the progress room, go down the corridor to the right and there will be a den area.
There will be a long cabinet across...
Oh, I think it's that.
Uh, on the left.
That one right there.
That one?
Okay, let me turn on the lights.
With this one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's one in there.
Somewhere.
Those are books.
Oh, there's...
There's videos.
There's also a second side.
Those are books.
It's on the other side.
Oh, I literally see it.
I literally see it.
I see it too, but you made me open the wrong cabinet.
Oh my god!
It's a whole cabinet!
Um, it's two cabinets!
It's two!
Oh my god.
You could have said left or right.
It didn't tell me!
Spanish or English.
What?
It...
Why is that there?
Yeah.
Wait, it was there.
It was there when you walked past.
No, it wasn't.
It was.
I did not see that before.
But I don't know.
I didn't...
I didn't pay attention to it.
Me too.
Yuck.
We know.
Okay.
Uh...
So now you can put in...
Indifference.
Oh no, sorry.
That was...
Affliction.
And now we gotta go get Greed.
Alright.
Wait, no.
We have two more.
We're missing two more.
What?
That one was all over the bottom...
First one.
So we're still missing two more.
Oh!
Okay.
Um...
Greed and...
Can I die in the loading room?
Can I...
Guys, can I die in the...
Stop moving!
I didn't go!
I'm trying to see!
It's literally the next two videos!
Not the last two!
Before addiction and after...
There's only!
Before addiction and after indifference.
Do you have negligence?
Wait, I can?
How do people kill me?
This is the level select!
Do you have negligence?
No.
Okay.
We need that.
Um, it's from Dolores' chapter.
Okay, but we're in Dolores' chapter.
Uh, complete the chapter...
Then enter the parents' room.
Okay.
Wait, do I have negligence?
Let me see.
I never actually...
I never really know.
I think we need negligence in green.
Okay.
That's in the parents' room.
So apparently I can die here.
So, like, that's not cool.
Well, it's all right.
You're not gonna die.
It's fine.
Okay, what if, like, somebody goes peekaboo and then I die?
Well, I mean, that would have happened anyway.
Okay, so, on the ground... I thought we grabbed this one.
Right there, that tape right there.
Oh, I did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I think, like, we did, but, like, it wasn't... It didn't save.
I must have, yeah, because I remember seeing this one.
Yeah.
Okay, that's why I thought we had it.
Okay, then we're good, and now we go to the basement.
All right.
Okay, that means if I can die here, I should save.
Oh, well, I... I was gonna say quick save.
Okay, um, apparently you can die in this... in the level select.
But we're... our sanity is so fine.
We're not gonna die.
It's fine.
Okay, all famous last words.
All right.
Okay, to the basement.
I think I know where the boiler room is.
Okay, so, remember there was, like, that hallway that you had to follow the scribbles in in the basement?
No.
Of course you don't.
What?
I never remember.
That's the best part about me.
Okay, go to the TV.
Okay.
Yeah.
And turn that way, yeah.
Turn to the left.
Yep.
Down that hall.
Wait, I can put a candle here.
And it's in that room that's open.
Let me put a candle here.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Now you care about the candles.
Okay.
Um, yes, because it actually helps me out.
And it's behind the boiler.
Oh, there it is.
See?
That's how I knew you hadn't gotten it.
Because why would you have checked there?
Okay.
Let me grab this.
All right.
Now what do we do?
Now...
Once you get them all... Once you... All the tapes have been collected, you'll need to play them in the VCR.
Keep them... Uh, yeah.
So...
Wait, give me a sec.
I need to grab a candle up.
Why?
You're going upstairs.
Because I need to light the candle!
Okay, I'm gonna try and not follow the guide now.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
Now... Now we can watch the video and hope we don't die in the level select.
We won't die!
Because if we die during the level select, we have to do this all over again.
It was only three tapes.
Okay.
It was three tapes.
That is still three too many.
You can't use that here?
I think you... There... What?
What?
Why don't you just put it inside the...
No.
Just put it in.
Yeah, put it in.
Yeah, just put it in.
No.
Yes!
Just put it in!
Okay, fine.
I need... I want to put the first tape in!
Okay, nice.
I don't think it matters.
Yes, it does.
It's... We gotta watch in order.
Okay.
All right.
Here you go.
Affliction.
Now watch the video.
All right.
Oh, baby.
There's a baby.
Stop.
I'm just wondering if something's coming over here!
Nothing's coming!
What is...
Oh.
What's that?
Wait, that's the well.
The well, yeah.
How'd you get in the well?
Why is...
We're gonna be cursed after watching this.
It's gonna ring.
A woman starts coming out of the TV.
Oh, wait.
Jesus is behind me.
He'll protect me.
Yeah, he'll protect us.
Jesus got your back.
Yeah, Jesus got me.
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
In seven days, we'll come back to Visage.
Oh, no!
In seven days, a part five of Visage comes out and it's just a video of us.
Oh, my God.
...crawling out of the TV.
Unless you send this stream to five friends!
Okay, I think that's the whole baby, right?
Yeah.
But, like, where do we...
There's a well?
I never saw a well.
We gotta...
Where the fuck is that?
There's other clues.
We gotta...
We gotta watch the other tapes.
No, I think, like, each tape tells us to go somewhere.
But where is that?
No, I don't think so.
It says, um...
Each tape will show scenes from a home video and flash a clue in certain segments in between.
Oh, okay.
Wait, once you finish playing a tape, something will occur in the house that will open up a secret area.
Oh!
Okay.
Maybe we should not watch all of them at once.
Yeah, I was gonna say, maybe that was a bad idea.
Oh, we're venting!
We're venting?
Venting, okay.
A little gear.
I mean...
Oh, I don't like that.
That's my baby.
I...
I don't...
What?
Who's the father?
Me.
Oh, you're like those liz...
Oh, I don't like that.
I...
I think you're gonna have to go in there.
Oh.
Oh, hey, there's that bird.
It's you!
It's me!
Gah!
There's Kroki!
Okay.
I guess that's all of the video.
All right, so we have two videos.
Greed and the other one.
Yeah.
All right, let's put those two back.
Actually, we keep holding it so we know that we...
Yeah, what we watched, right?
Um...
Where is the two?
Why don't you look around the house a little bit?
Okay.
Why are we speedrunning, huh?
Um...
It's not like I have to scroll through the guide to find out, anyway.
Wait, we watched what?
We watched Greed and...
It's Greed and...
Let me...
I think it was Affliction.
Let me look.
It was Greed and...
Affliction, yeah.
Okay.
I don't feel so good.
Which one do you want to do first?
Let's do...
Let's do the creepy...
Um...
Well thing.
Let's do the ring one first.
The ring one I feel more comfort in in the...
In your baby.
Oh, I think it's up here.
What's going on there?
Oh, I think I can die now.
Wait, the table must be something, no?
The table right there?
They said don't grab it yet.
I think I can die now.
Why?
This does not look safe.
Oh, that thing's been swinging the whole time.
No, I meant that.
Oh, the mold.
The black...
The black mold?
That came from your fridge, no?
That...
I think...
Oh, yeah, it's true.
My fridge.
I haven't cleaned in a while.
That might be why I'm sick.
Yeah, I am.
Okay.
We've all got a little bit of mold.
Got a little bit of mold inside of us.
Okay, so...
Yeah.
Where should I go?
Downstairs, right?
I feel like...
Okay, affliction.
Oh, there's a lot of them.
Yeah, there's a lot of mold.
I don't feel comfortable anymore.
It says you need the crowbar, so you're gonna have to get it from the storage room.
Okay.
Why is there a lot of black mold now?
I...
I thought this was supposed to be the good end.
Oh, my God.
I need to have two hands!
I hate the...
The inventory management in this game actually makes, like...
Tilt...
Makes me tilt it.
It's so bad.
I don't understand!
If...
Pick it up!
What do you mean I can only have two?
Oh, my God.
Do I have it in my...
Okay, I have it in my hand.
I have it in my hand.
Okay.
Where do I have to go?
You have it?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Um...
All right.
It feels like it's gonna take you a while to read this.
Let me...
Return to the first floor and enter the room with the mirror on the door.
The mirror on the door?
Oh, the one where we started the granny!
The granny chapter.
I remember where that is.
Maybe.
All right.
The granny chapter.
Okay.
So, it's here.
I do not feel comfortable with the black mold.
Don't worry about the black mold.
Okay.
Wait.
No, there's no mirror on the door.
It says, uh...
Yeah, it says.
This is the mirror.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Yeah.
Look at the floorboards near the door.
Oh, is this?
Must be.
What do you mean you can't use that here?
Okay, you fucking liar.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Why is this all so convoluted?
There's, like, no hints.
How are we supposed to know?
I mean, it's different colored.
So, you know, like, in cartoons.
Tunes where something's a different color.
Yeah, but, like, they're just like, Hey, you need to go to the well.
We didn't know there was a well underneath here.
How are we supposed to know?
I don't know.
How do they...
People play this?
Who uses this out?
How do people play this without guides?
Oh, they have to buy the...
You know those little gamer guides back in the day?
Like...
Wait.
I don't need this anymore, right?
Let's just hope I don't need this.
Oh, yeah.
You can drop it.
Yeah.
You know, like, those gamer guides you buy at GameStop?
That's how I figured things out.
This feels like Outlast all of a sudden.
Like, Outlast 2.
Oh, that's...
Oh, I never played Outlast 2.
I played Outlast 1.
I thought...
I heard Outlast 2 isn't as good as Outlast 1.
Oh, hey.
There's the bunker.
Oh, there's the thing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hello.
Oh, hey.
Whoa.
Okay.
I'm in a secret laboratory.
Factory.
What the fuck...
What the fuck was going on down here, Dolores?
Did you make this all yourself?
Okay.
I don't...
I feel like...
I feel like we're in a different game.
Yeah.
Me too.
Resident Evil.
This is Umbrella Corp right now.
Oh, I hope not.
Might be worse than Dolores.
Yeah, but then they give you a gun.
Am I going to get a gun now?
Oh, true.
True.
Yeah, true.
It's better because I get a gun.
Yeah, this feels like the guy...
You know that woman that built an underground mine shaft?
Yes!
The lady who just started digging underneath her.
Yeah.
And had, like, no perms to do it.
And she was like, I learned everything from YouTube videos.
Okay, you pressed it?
I pressed it?
Oh, I moved down here.
There's a pathway down here.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, Dolores built...
Instead of building a mine shaft, she literally built an entire fucking secret laboratory.
Oh, yeah.
And then, like, the government...
This is literally Dexter's lab.
Yeah, and then apparently the government had to shut her...
The government had to shut her down because it was, like...
It could have almost collapsed her entire home and her neighbor's home.
Yeah.
Because she was not building proper foundations.
She was just digging away.
Yeah, she was watching YouTube videos and digging away.
She literally had no degree for doing this.
Well, she also wasn't very secret about it because she was posting all of her...
So, like...
Yeah, she's like, day four, I'm building my underground mine shaft.
Yeah.
What did you think was going to happen, Dolores?
When she got the permit?
That's the...
No.
The proof?
The permit.
Wow.
I mean, I guess...
I feel sorry.
Where'd the ambiance go?
I don't like that.
I feel sorry for her neighbors.
Where'd the ambiance go?
Wait, I have...
Wait, I have to pause the game.
I got a call from the vet.
I'll be right back.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you go entertain, chat.
Hey, guys.
How's it going?
Ugh.
Stalling.
This isn't stalling this time.
The vet's important.
I suppose.
Ugh, guys, I didn't like my dinner, so I'm still hungry.
Hmm.
Oh, man.
It's like the worst thing ever.
When you're like...
Want to eat something good, and then it's just...
Do I have snacks?
I have some snacks.
Yeah, I got some snacks.
What did I eat?
It was like a...
It was like a fish plate.
Like some rice and fish.
But...
It's just...
I don't...
I didn't like the way the fish tasted.
So...
Hmm.
I don't know.
Hopefully it wasn't bad.
Scoop sushi.
I don't think it was bad fish.
It's just happening.
It happens sometimes.
But now I'm kind of just like...
Ugh.
I'm not satisfied.
I ate.
I ate most of it.
But I'm like...
I don't feel good about it.
I want something delicious.
Nutritious.
Eat, Doki.
I don't think I'll do that.
Can you do a Yoda voice?
Yoda say what?
What is something...
What is something that Yoda says?
I'm not...
You...
What's something Yoda says?
It's a funny joke.
Wait.
Yoda talks backwards, no?
So it'd be like...
It'd be like...
Oh gosh.
What?
No JP grammar.
Wait.
He doesn't speak Japanese?
No.
He doesn't speak Japanese.
He is...
He speaks...
Wait.
I don't know how Japanese grammar works.
Uh...
Um...
I...
Yoda-chan.
Hi!
What do you like?
Choco mint.
You're more...
I wonder what the Yoda JP dub sounds like.
Hold on, I'm gonna look for it.
I'll play it in my speaker and I'll speak it.
Hold on.
Yoda.
Japanese dub.
Okay.
Can you hear it?
Wait.
Which one's Yoda?
Oh, that's...
He just sounds like an old man.
That's... That's... That's... Obi-Wan.
Oh, this is Yoda.
This is the Obi-Wan.
This is Yoda.
He just sounds like an old man.
Wait, is this Obi-Wan in the movie?
Wait, is it Obi-Wan or Obi-Wan?
What does... What's his name when he meets...
Wait, or...
The...
In the first movie?
What's his name?
Obi-Wan.
Okay.
Obi... Obi... Obi-Wanna.
Obi-Wanna.
Sushi.
Ben Kenobi.
Old man Ben?
Who?
Who's Ben Kenobi?
Wait.
I thought we were talking about Obi-Wan.
Obi...
One...
Kenobi.
Legendary...
Yeah, that's the guy that meets Yoda, right?
Wait.
Oh, I was talking about...
That wasn't Obi-Wan Kenobi.
That was...
Luke Skywalker.
Oh, okay.
So in that clip, it was not Obi-Wan.
That was Luke Skywalker talking to...
To...
Oh my gosh.
The title of the video is literally Luke meets Yoda.
All I saw was the Japanese dub part.
Sorry.
How long is this...
To call for?
Obi-Wan.
No, sorry.
Luke Skywalker.
Do you think there's like a sky crawler?
Sky runner?
Sky jumper?
Sky skipper?
Star Wars fans frothing at the mouth?
I've never seen it.
I've never seen any Star Wars.
I just like the way that...
That...
Stormtroopers look.
I think they're really cute.
Skycrawler.
That's when he was born.
He was born as Skycrawler.
Then he turned into a Skywalker.
Wait.
He...
Skywalker.
So he could Skyrunner.
Blade Runner.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I think I'm onto something here.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Blade Runner.
He was a Skywalker.
They fly.
They have flying cars.
Stars in Blade Runner.
Oh.
No.
Wait.
Oh my god.
And Blade Runner has robots.
And so does...
Star Wars.
And...
What if...
3CPO...
No, no, no.
R2-D2...
Is the prototype...
Of...
The sexy lady...
That he falls in love with...
In Blade Runner.
So Skywalkers...
So they could Blade Runner.
I hardly even know her.
I'm not burning anything.
I'm cooking the truth.
Oh my god.
And Harrison Ford is in both.
No way.
It's inedible.
It's not inedible.
It's real.
It's the truth.
That's enough Nancy Drew for you.
Hey, hey, hey.
Guys.
I have a question to ask.
I'm not even gonna ask if I can ask it.
What's your family trauma?
How...
If you have a family member that died...
That died...
How did that happen?
And I need...
Nobody is telling me...
How the family member died.
Even though it's so...
It's so...
Personal.
But...
I just have to know because I'm Nancy Drew.
Eaten by mint.
And that's why you have a vendetta against me.
Drowned in a tub.
Wait.
That's what happened to Nancy Drew.
Sorry.
You guys don't actually have to tell me.
I was...
I played Nancy Drew earlier.
And she just always asks...
Really insensitive questions.
Oh.
Hello?
All right.
I'm back.
Hello.
All right.
Yeah.
So I told Min about what was going on earlier before the stream started.
But the reason why the vet was calling is that we had to take him back to the vet again today.
Because he wasn't eating last night.
And he wasn't eating this morning.
And he was also having diarrhea.
So we were wondering if it was like a side effect from the medication he's on.
Because he's on like four different types of meds.
Because it was like post-surgery.
So we had to do like several blood tests and like scans and stuff to see if there's like anything wrong with his kidneys.
And so what we found out is that he might be a genetic mess.
Oh no!
Because like they're like, yeah, like apparently he lacks protein.
And I was like, how?
Like I was like, he eats so much protein.
How does he lack protein?
So like they're saying like, oh, he might have got by because like it was okay.
But the meds might have like messed up with his like, like made it more apparent that he like couldn't, he lacked the protein.
I didn't really understand food because it was all like medical jargon.
So they might call me again because like, um, um, he obviously he was like vomiting and diarrhea.
So like he was like not, uh, not comfortable with eating and stuff.
Um, because he, you know, he was vomiting and stuff.
So he was like not happy about it.
Um, and then so, uh, but like he would, what's funny was that my dog sitter was like, oh yeah, like he didn't eat his dog food, but then we gave him like half a hot dog and he devoured it.
It's just like, you fucker.
He was like, I don't want dog food, but if I'm going to throw up, I'm going to eat this.
I don't care.
I'm going to eat this hot dog.
My cat is like, it could be that he associated the food with throwing up.
Yeah.
I think that's what he last ate.
So, so like, um, so we, he just got through, like, uh, he got through like the, we just got the results from the blood test.
And like, obviously they're like, yeah, like he has low levels of like protein and like something else and stuff like that.
And then he, they were asking me like, oh, did he ever have like vomiting issues or diarrhea issues?
I was like, not really.
I mean, like I had like maybe like once every couple of like maybe a couple months he would suddenly randomly throw up some like saliva or water.
But like, other than that, like, it's not, it doesn't happen like a lot.
Like it happens like very rarely.
And then they're like, oh, it might be like the medication that he was on that like, like made it worse type deal.
So it made it more noticeable.
So he was getting by, like, didn't really matter for him.
Um, but yeah, you know how...
So, and they're like, oh yeah, so are you okay with us doing more tests later?
To make sure, like, do like a CT scan, like an ultra scan later, just to make sure of everything.
And I was like, yeah, no problem.
Because, you know, you know, when you, for your, for your, for your pet, you're like, just try and fix everything.
And they're like, all right, we'll call you later.
So you can put your deposit in.
And they're like, it's not soap.
And the entire house is like, okay.
So it's like, on top of, it's another, it's another 5K going in there today.
Oh my God.
Are you going to an emergency vet?
That's so expensive.
It was like a, well, yeah, we had to take him to the ER today.
Um, because like, we were worried since like, you know, he already has his back.
Like, like it was post-surgery.
So we were worried about like him not eating and him being dehydrated and stuff.
And it's also like a specialist too, because it's for like a neurological specialist.
And, um, uh, and so that, so that's why it's like much more expensive because like, it's actually, there's only like one spec, like there's only like one or two specialists there that focuses on like neurological problems within animals.
So it's like a lot more expensive.
But then like, you know, after the whole blood work thing and stuff like that, cause they're like, we got to have to sedate him to do the ultrasound, you know, cause it's like scanning.
They're like, we're going to check to see if he ate already before, before we do this.
And then they're like, like, we're also in the phone call and they're like, Hey, has like, has Dookie ate yet?
Cause I named the dog after myself.
Um,
and then, and then, and then they're like, Oh, he ate everything.
Oh, sorry.
They're like, Oh, he ate it all.
So clearly he's feeling okay now.
Like right now he's feeling great because he like, apparently consumed all the dog food that he was given.
And then they're like, Oh, so yeah, we can't really do the sedation because we didn't think he was going to eat all the food because they can sedate a pet while when they're already full.
So they're like, we're going to call you later for the deposit.
And also like to see if we have an open schedule because it's Friday too.
So they're like, we had to do on Friday.
We do it on Monday.
So, Oh no, cause there's no specialist on the weekend.
So they're like, we're going to see if there's an open schedule to, you know, have him do the scan so he could digest it and then do the scan.
Why did they give him the food then?
Cause like, I think they, uh, cause he didn't have any much to eat too.
So then I, I think they didn't think I was going to go through the, the, the, the ultrasound scan cause it was like more money.
And I was like, you don't understand.
He is family.
You need to get, you need to get pet insurance.
I do.
I, I, I do.
I realized like what the amount, like I didn't realize how much of a genetic freak he is, but now I, now I'm definitely getting pet insurance after that.
Cause I have to do that for my cat.
Yeah.
I mean, you're, I mean, your cat is, what's it called?
An incest baby.
Yeah.
Well, not for him.
Oh, so I adopted the other cat.
So I got her and like, she would like poop on the floor and there would be blood in it.
Oh my God, what?
Yeah.
And so I took her to the vet and they were like, might be parasites.
So kind of like monitor how her poop is like.
Yeah.
But still she will like poop on the floor and she just poops on the floor constantly.
I'm always cleaning up her shit on the floor.
And I'm like, I can't, I can't deal with this anymore.
Oh my God.
And she like, she has like problems going, I think it's still, I think like the parasites will go into remission and then like, they can't see them.
And then, why can't they get rid of the parasites?
Well, they are just like, we don't know for sure if she has them.
So I've taken her back to the vet several times and I'm like, okay, I'm going to.
I'm going to get peniturized.
I'm going to get peniturized for her.
Yeah.
Cause she'll go to the bathroom in the litter box and then she'll be like, Nope, I got to go again.
And then go on the floor.
Just go next to the floor.
Does she have to poop next to the litter?
Yes, right next to the litter.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Oh yeah.
So yeah, like, oh yeah, that reminds me.
So the issue right now is that they were like, yeah, like he's like peeing out like bits of his kidney.
And I was like, what?
Like, but like, no, it's not like actual kidney kidney.
It's like, like when a kidney is like, seems to be a bit damaged, like you can pee it out apparently.
And then they're like, yeah.
So we're going to, we don't know.
They're like, like, they're like, has your vet ever like said anything about that?
And I was like, no, like that's new.
Like, I was like, that was like the protein thing.
So like, yeah.
So I was like, that's new.
Could that be like kidney stones?
I have no idea.
And, um, and so I was just, they're like, okay, so yeah.
I mean, he seems okay right now, but like, uh, we're just going to do more tests to be like, what's going on?
And, um, yeah, so they're like, I think it could be like, they're like, I think it could be genetic wise.
And I was like, how much of a freak are you?
How old is he?
He's, um, he's currently seven.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, um.
I don't know how long weenie dogs live for.
Well, small dogs live a long, a lot longer than, uh, yeah, they live longer than big dogs.
Um, but like, yeah, so, oh, they're just calling me again.
I'll be back.
Okay.
Oh, seven.
Cat pooping on the floor is usually a sign of an issue.
Yeah, I know.
That's why I have to take her back to the vet.
I just haven't had time.
And also it's like $500 a visit.
So I'm like, I'm like, uh, like, obviously I'll do it, but I haven't had time recently.
So, uh, uh, pets.
Oh, pets.
They're so expensive and they're so annoying.
But they're, they are, they are, they are everything.
But, well, that also cure pauses fart problems.
I don't know.
Maybe.
I feel like it's all, it has to all be connected, though.
I was like, I don't know if she has IBS or if it's parasites.
Like, I've changed her food and a couple times and now she has a little bit more solid poops than she used.
Like, it used to be straight liquid.
Sorry if you're eating.
But, you know, ask Nancy Drew.
Yeah, pretty much.
So, that's what I, worms, I say, worms, parasites, I mean them in the same way.
But, like, I feel, she's had this ever since I got her.
I feel like the shelter would have been like, hey, by the way, we tested her and they, she had something.
And we treated it.
Or we tested her and there was nothing.
I don't know what, from the time we took her from the crate to my car, she suddenly got worms somehow.
I don't know.
Oh.
Back again.
I'm back again.
Alright, so, yeah, they called me.
They're like, we can't do the scan today because he ate too much.
They're like, yeah, he ate too much.
We can't sedate him.
So, we're going to do it on Monday.
That's okay.
And I was like, yeah, that's fine.
And they're like, oh, yeah, do you want to keep...
Because he's staying at the pet hospital for another day.
Just because I was like, you know, professionals.
Are looking after him.
Yeah.
And they're like, oh, yeah, we could discharge him tomorrow if you want.
Or keep him there.
And I was like, we'll see...
They're like, we'll see tomorrow how he's like.
And then if tomorrow he's like, okay, we can discharge him.
And then you bring him back on Monday.
And then I was just like, no, just keep him there.
Like, I was like, I didn't want to, like...
I'm like, I don't want him to, like, come back and decide it.
He'd be like, I'm going to show you a new symptom.
Like, because, like, every day...
Like, I was just like, I don't want to, like, deal with that.
Because I don't want to...
Yeah, I was like, he's already there.
They're like, we'll talk about it more tomorrow.
Because I was like, I'm okay if you keep him in the hospital for a few more days.
Because I don't want to worry about a new symptom that shows up randomly.
No, I guess that's fair.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
And it would stress him out, taking him back and forth.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking, too.
And then, like, at best, like, I could, like, visit him and stuff.
Just so he'll be, like, more fine with, like, you know, have, like, familiar face.
I think, like, that's the thing they're worried about.
Because, like, you know, when they're like, where's my owner?
And stuff like that.
Yeah.
But, like, I'm also really worried.
Like, because, like, I'm worried that just another...
Like, I think it was just a negative side...
Because they're saying that it could be a negative side effect to all the fucking meds he's on right now.
Yeah, I feel like that could be a normal case.
Yeah, and then, like, because, like, there's, like, they said, like, one of the side effects from one of the medications he's taken is, like, it would upset the kidneys and the stomach in general.
It was like, I don't know what they said.
There's so many medical jargon.
It was like, gastric something.
And I was like, I totally understand.
I was just like, yeah, yeah.
I don't understand.
But like, clearly, you know much better than me.
Especially if it's a bunch of meds all at once.
Yeah, yeah.
He has to take four at once.
So like, yeah, because like, he literally got back surgery.
Yeah, so yeah, we're gonna see...
But like, he's eating now.
He's eating.
He's drinking water now, which is great.
And it's mostly just like, we're just trying to see, like, why he wasn't eating.
And why he was getting diarrhea and vomiting.
So obviously, that's more money.
But like, it's okay.
I have another sponsor next week.
So it's okay.
But thank you everybody for the super chats.
I really, really appreciate it.
I'm their sponsor next week, which is gonna help a lot.
So all the sponsor money is going towards him right now.
But yeah, that's a dog update right now.
I mean, the vet said he's healthy.
Like, not... Okay, I won't say healthy.
But he's happy right now.
He's not bad.
He's just a little guy.
They said that he's doing okay right now.
And he's like, eating and drinking, which is...
Yeah, stable.
Yeah, he's stable.
He's stable.
Like, that was what we were worried about.
Because like, last night, he wasn't eating until we gave him a half a hot dog.
And then this morning, he didn't eat.
But now he's eating now.
So like, you know, that's already good.
And that's good for me.
Because it's like, look, he's eating.
But also, if like, they discover something about...
Like, from doing the test.
Something else that he needs to be on medication for.
It could have all been worth it.
Like, say he was just upset from the meds.
Like, but they also discovered that he had like the kidney thing.
Like, that would be, you know, a good reason to also have everything done.
So I wouldn't feel like, oh, he just was upset from the meds.
Like, it's also good that if they...
Yeah, they just found this, like the hidden disease that triggered it.
He might have like something hidden in there.
In there.
Because they said like, oh, it's possible that he has something called this, this disease.
I don't remember anymore.
But they were like, it could be like this, this disease that he has.
That could have been triggered by the medication.
And it was like underlying.
It was just like, you know, it wasn't that bad before.
But because the medication triggered it, that's why he's vomiting and having diarrhea.
And I was like, oh, that makes sense.
It didn't make sense to me.
But like, I was like, that makes sense.
It does make sense.
That makes sense.
He's a messed up little guy.
He's just a messed up genetic freak.
But we love him.
Yeah.
He doesn't know that.
As long as he lives his life knowing that he's not a messed up freak.
Then it's okay.
Okay, they're calling me again.
Okay.
Again?
I was going to say, are they, I was literally about to ask, are they calling you?
I was about to say, are they going to call her again?
Uh.
Okay.
Um.
I was, because I was going to go get some water.
Yeah.
Yes, I understand.
Doesn't understand at all.
Say, Kate, it's you, PS.
How many phone calls do you get?
JK, guys.
Just the UPS.
It's not, it's not the vet.
I, I, I lost track of phone calls.
I was like, hello.
And they're like, it's UPS.
And I was like, oh.
Turns off, turns off nice voice.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like, you know, the polite voice you use on phone calls.
Hello?
Oh, UPS.
Oh, okay.
I'll be like, okay.
All right.
Nah, nah, nothing.
I was like, why did they call?
I was like, oh my God, they call back so fast.
What happened?
I know what I was going to say.
And then, it's just UPS.
I'm going to go get water real quick.
Okay.
Maybe a snack.
And you can keep playing the game.
No, it's okay.
I don't want you to miss out.
I don't, yeah, no, I'll wait for you.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
It is an emergency.
It's UPS, guys.
I actually don't know what the delivery is.
I have so many...
Oh my gosh.
Do I have anything coming today?
I just...
I don't know.
I have so many delivery stuff coming over here.
But like, some of them are like...
Oh, it could be gamer subs.
It's always...
They always send me free stuff.
I won't be surprised if it's just...
If it's just more gamer subs things.
Because they're always sending me free stuff.
So...
I was just like, what...
What am I supposed to be getting during the UPS?
And I was like, oh, yeah.
Because like, if you're partnered with gamer subs, every month you get like a free package of like...
Of like, you know, whatever they're releasing at that time.
So...
I think it was like every other month or something.
They always give you...
They always give you some...
A free package of stuff.
So...
Yeah.
I can't wait.
I don't ever have to buy...
Never have to buy...
Use my code...
By the way, you can use my code DokiBird for 15% off on all your purchases.
Even on the mint stuff, too.
Oh, it could be...
No, it does.
It's not mint stuff.
Because like...
It tells you me...
It tells me what the free things are.
Because I would get an email about it.
And then it lists like all...
Like the stuff there.
And I remember it was not related to mint.
It's like some other promotion that they're doing.
But I don't remember.
Use code DokiBird, by the way.
But yes, thank you guys.
Thank you all for the super chats.
I thought you named yourself after the...
No, I named the dog after me.
I came first.
I was there first.
And then I named my dog after me.
Because I'm an egomaniac.
Let's play the game.
Oh, hello.
Yeah.
I'll send them.
I think the UPS package was a gamer subs package.
Because they always send us free stuff.
No way.
I think so.
Because I was like, what else am I getting?
I was like, they always, they always, you know how they always send us free things every other month?
Yeah.
So we have like a whole collection of like gamer subs stuff.
So much.
There's so much.
Like, I have like, I have like, I have like a, like the, like, what is it called?
Like a cabinet filled with just like the gamer subs powder.
Like that's...
Do you actually drink it?
I actually do.
When I'm like, instead of caffeine, I actually drink the, the powder.
Because like, it's free.
So I don't have to buy coffee, you know?
Well, I'll make like pictures of it.
Wait, you make pictures?
What?
Like, I have like, you know, like a pitcher of water.
Like I make a pitcher of it.
And then if I have a...
Or you just put it in the fridge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's smart.
I mean, it's free.
So like, and there's like some natural...
It's free.
And you can get 15% off.
It might not be free, but it's still 15% off.
If you use code DokiBird on mince or on mince.
Is it 15?
Is that a 10 or 15?
I don't know.
I thought it was 10.
Oh, is it 10%?
Yeah.
Typical Doki lying on the internet.
You'll, you'll get 10% off of the order if you use Boomer.
And it's not a lie.
And you get 15% off on mince items that you use DokiBird to.
No, it's 10.
False advertising.
Okay, now you're actually stalling.
Let's play it again.
Well, do you know what my UPS order is?
No!
Wait, are you actually waiting for that?
I don't know.
I'm going to check outside right now.
Give me a sec.
Oh, my God!
We're never going to finish this.
It has become ultimate...
We...
I should have stopped her as soon as...
The second...
After the second phone call, I should have been like...
This is it.
We're going to...
You didn't come up to my floor.
So, I think...
Oh, wait.
They're calling me.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, my God!
I was like, I got another phone call.
You are screaming!
You are working!
I got another phone call!
Wait, what did they call me?
What did they call...
Okay.
I don't know.
This is the most phone calls I've ever got during work.
I'm so popular.
I'm so...
I'm so popular, guys.
Alright.
Escape to resume.
Where was I?
Oh, here.
Yeah, here.
Open up.
Knock, knock.
Daddy's home.
Daddy's here.
Lucy.
Lucy?
I was watching something, and they referenced Lucy, and I was just like...
I was like, no.
I can't.
I can't do this again.
What am I supposed to do?
I just walked forward?
I guess so.
I don't like this.
Wait, there's something at the door.
You see that?
There's a face there.
You see that face?
You stream in such low quality, I can't tell, actually.
No, it's...
Oh, wait.
No, it's not.
It's a door.
Whoops.
Oh, see?
Okay, now you just need glasses.
Okay, it looked like a face, though.
Okay.
I don't know about that.
Okay, apparently I need to find a card, wherever that is.
Oh, no.
I have to explore it.
Okay.
Time to explore.
It's probably, like, right here.
I don't know that.
This game is never generous.
Oh, my God.
It's not a generous...
Oh, you see that off-colored locker?
Compared to...
It definitely couldn't be...
Oh, it's locked.
Okay, that's not cool.
Oh, what about the...
Oh, those are trees.
I thought it was, like, blood on them.
Okay, that's not cool.
It's locked.
I don't like that.
Okay.
Keep looking around.
Oh, there's a...
See, there's another door.
Yeah, there's another...
I guess I have to go to that door and then go to the other side.
Alright.
Here I go.
God, I wish I could just run.
Like, did I just lose the use of my feet?
Afterwards?
You might have.
Like, why can't I...
Why can't I only, like, walk?
Doesn't make sense.
I don't know.
He might be tired.
Why are you so tired?
Wake up, Dad.
Wake up.
Knock, knock.
I don't like this.
Wait, are we back at the hospital?
Are we back in the hospital?
Yeah.
No way.
Oh, we are.
Wait, this is the hospital.
Wait, no, it's just a cafeteria.
Oh!
Hey, who is Taylor?
Who is Taylor?
Who the heck is that?
Who the fuck knows?
Because that's the locker, right?
Maybe.
Probably.
Oh.
Ah!
Turn on!
Oh my God!
He's just walking towards me!
Well, you're walking away, so it works.
I don't think that's gonna work.
Wait, I did it.
Wait, it did.
Oh my God.
I thought you were gonna hide up there.
No, I didn't know.
Oh my God, he's leaving his footprints.
Wait, there was a door on the other side.
I don't know if he can get through this.
No?
I'll try.
Oh, goodbye, I guess.
Yeah.
Wait, what if I loop him?
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, I don't like that.
So close.
Ew!
I don't like it.
Oh my God, why would he look into my eyes while that happened?
That was so...
I don't like that.
I don't like how he looked into my eyes as if there's, like, a connection there.
Hopefully the autosave was when he picked up the key.
Me too.
I hope so, too.
I hope so.
I don't want to do all the videos again.
No, and it can't be that far away.
It is...
Oh, yeah, it was very wet.
Uh...
Oh, it's back here, okay.
Okay, just go up that side.
Yeah.
And then just pick up the key.
Wait.
Where do I go, then?
There was a door on the other side.
It was lit up.
Oh.
Wait, where?
This one?
No, no, no.
No.
Um...
Oh, so...
See that?
It's dark right now.
Right there.
See, it's kind of lit up right now.
That door over there, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, the vent!
No?
I don't think so.
See, there's that door right there.
Can you not get to that?
See?
On the other side of the room!
Can you not get to that?
No.
Oh.
I think...
Yeah, it's the vent.
Yeah.
Oh, you do go through the vent.
I was like...
What door?
It was lit up when I saw it, though.
I swear.
Sure it was.
Someone didn't take her mitts!
Wait, how do I...
Oh.
Okay, I have to, like...
See him.
You have to activate it, yeah.
And be like...
There's somebody here.
Nope.
Keep going.
What the fuck?
You have to go over there.
The lights will flicker.
Oh, okay.
I see him.
Alright.
There's, like...
There's no reason to go in there.
And I was like...
I can see it off the beach here.
Why not?
I know.
I was like, why not?
He's literally right there.
God, like...
Wow.
That's so smooth.
Vent time.
Surely nothing's gonna chase me in the vents, right?
No.
Wait.
Can you activate your lighter?
Is that why there's black mold?
Because of the vents?
No.
Because of the tar, man.
Because of the mold, man.
No, he's obviously tar.
That's not mold.
Okay.
But, like...
That means there's tar on my...
On my ceiling.
What is he?
Spider-Man?
It's Venom.
It's pre...
Venom has taken another host.
It's because he's not...
It's because it's not Tom Hardy.
It's, like, some regular guy.
What if he's still chasing after you?
Don't say that.
I'm looking backwards.
It only makes the game longer.
All right.
Time to take the locker.
Open up.
Oh, there's the key card.
Oh.
I don't even know how to read that.
He's, he's, he's, like...
I feel like this room is perfect for looping.
He's gonna be right there.
Don't say that.
He's gonna...
No, he's not.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have a perfect escape right here at the bottom of the stairs.
And there's gonna be no one waiting for me.
Can you jump in this game?
No.
I can flick my lighter back and forth.
It's just like that.
Beep, beep.
Oh.
Oh, he's gonna come.
And I open the door.
And then I close the door behind me.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
The music was so ominous.
It's like, door open.
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, that's a lot of tar.
I mean...
I wonder if this is all the pieces we have to get.
Like, see how they're all branched.
Oh, that's true.
No, actually, this is from the vision, though.
This is from the tape, I mean.
Oh, the, the, the, the, the, the, the well.
The well, yeah.
I'm gonna take the apple.
From the snake.
Oh, don't do it, Eve!
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, I...
Snake?
Gladly.
Something gonna...
And then the ring girl's gonna pop up.
And be like, send this to five different people.
Send this playthrough to five different people.
Or Doe Kitty.
That's a fat apple.
And Mink Kitty is gonna pop out of your screen.
Mink Kitty.
Oh.
That's a juicy apple right there.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yum, yum, yum.
Eat it.
Oh, oh.
Eat that.
That's what happens when he...
Oh.
Oh, no.
I feel like something's gonna come out.
Do a flip.
Jump in.
Come on, you know you want to.
Am I not gonna jump in?
Am I a coward?
I can't control it.
I know this is probably all symbolism, but I have no idea what's happening.
What's going on?
Oh, somebody's gonna come up and grab me.
I'm gonna touch the water?
What's wrong with me?
He's thirsty.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What's going on?
What?
Ass up.
Join us.
Oh, look at all these asses.
Oh, that one's so perky.
You see that perky one over there?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, with the extra shine.
Extra shine.
They're all assed up, except the first guy.
He's shy.
He's really shy.
He's like, you gotta work for this.
Oh.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my god, there's tar guy.
I don't like it.
Solid snake ass drink.
Snake.
I was promised a woman coming out of the well.
What is this?
Yeah.
What happened?
My Japanese whore lied to me.
Yeah.
You remember when they did, like, the ring girl versus...
Oh, my god.
Yes.
I thought that movie was so bad.
You watched it?
I love the ads for it.
The ads for it were really funny.
So, like, there's a lot in the ring.
Um, novel that they did not add it, like, adapt into the movie.
Like, it's very...
The ring is actually really, really weird.
And, like, in the movie, in the, in the, um...
In the versus movie, they kind of...
What are you...
Oh, you're saving?
Yeah, they said I can't automatically save, so I got scared.
Okay.
I think that was a checkpoint.
But, um...
There's, like, some things that they did adapt for the movie that they didn't, like...
From the novel that they did for that movie.
And it's, like, she grows, like, frog legs.
There's, like, a frog version of her.
And, like...
It's just very strange.
It's...
There's a lot that is not in the movies.
Okay, where do I go now?
She grows...
Wait, so you read that book?
No, I didn't read the book, but, like, I read about the book.
Oh, there's a collectible in there.
Oh, we don't need that.
No, that's definitely where the Tired Man comes out.
That's...
That's definitely where...
Okay, so where do we go for the next, uh...
For the next one?
Remember the one with, like...
It was Greed, right?
Yeah.
Or was it Affliction?
I don't know.
We just did Affliction.
Okay.
So where do we get for Greed?
Hold on.
One moment.
The Greed was at the top.
Okay.
After...
Notice how the tape shows the inside of a vent.
Yeah, we saw that.
Go down to the basement.
Boiler room.
Okay.
Wait, that...
Oh!
Okay.
Yeah, we're right there, actually.
Where was the boiler room?
Nope, turn around.
Turn around.
We're right there.
To the left.
There we go.
And...
Oh, I don't know.
I think that's it.
Oh.
Like, no, no.
Wait.
No, no, no.
There it is.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, I thought it was the hole in the boiler.
No, no, no.
I was like...
I thought it was the hole in the boiler.
Oh, I hurt myself.
I'm a pathetic man.
Yeah, you are.
How did my weight...
Broke it?
Sorry, I had ice cream today.
I hurt myself today.
Okay.
All right.
Wait, um, you need that stepladder.
You need the stepladder.
I broke the stepladder.
Like, I don't know.
We can fix it.
Wait, no way.
What did you saw?
There was a...
Oh.
Oh my god, it was my lighter.
My lighter, like, ran at me.
Okay.
Oh, I'm sorry.
We have to find a new stepladder.
Okay, where's the deuce stepladder?
I don't know.
Look around.
What do you mean, look around?
It's in the basement.
But where in the basement?
Oh my god.
You are not a very helpful...
You're not getting a tip for this guide work.
I was gonna get tipped?
Yeah, you know how, like, tour guides get, like, tips for doing a good job?
Someone that was definitely not doing a good job.
Well, you weren't going to tip me regardless, so...
I could have!
I could have Akasuped you on your channel.
You wouldn't.
No, you wouldn't.
Yes, I would have.
No, you wouldn't have.
I would have.
I'm a very generous person.
Oh, there he is.
See, I didn't need your help.
We'll need your help later.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Just close the door.
Oh my god!
Okay.
No!
Just drop it.
Okay, I need to drop.
Oh my god, I hate...
I hate all these controls.
Ew, it's like talking.
It's creepy.
Ew!
I'm trying to grab...
I don't want to hear the baby anymore.
You're gonna hear this baby.
You're gonna hear the baby.
The baby.
Alright, now I can...
Now you can do it.
Alright.
The baby.
Is there a...
I hear a woof.
Is that a dog on your end?
Yeah, there's a dog on your end.
Oh my god, it's like...
It's like...
Who's barking right now?
Alright.
Someone's probably walking their dog.
Woof!
Alright.
I'm just gonna go straight until I can.
I assume I have to go straight until...
It tells me to stop.
Yeah, probably.
Wait, how many tapes were there?
Seven?
Oh my god.
But that...
They're like mini chapters.
That one was so...
That wasn't so fast.
Oh my god.
It just took a long time because you got five calls in the middle of it.
That's true.
I'm a very important person, apparently.
You don't give a fuck.
Wait, actually, I don't want to sign a contract.
Let me read...
You're gonna sign that?
I'm never doing that again.
What does this mean?
Yeah, I would like to please have a lawyer read this.
Please.
Wait, you're...
The bird is there.
Yeah, I know.
Wait, it's you.
It's me.
They're like signing the contract.
Sign.
You know, you want to sign it.
Sign it.
From one bird to another.
Yeah.
Okay, I guess I'll sign the contract.
I gotta do a part of my soul.
It just says you don't give a fuck like eight times.
Oh, it does underneath it too?
Okay.
Yeah.
So edgy.
Whoa.
Yeah, it's time to sign.
What are we...
What does that mean, though?
Should we just stop giving a fuck?
If we give a fuck, then we...
We break the contract.
They're like, you did it.
Yippee!
You signed the contract.
Oh.
I signed the contract.
They also signed the contract.
Can you use your lighter?
I don't think I can.
I think we'll have to do that thing where...
We're like, where we can't...
In the hospital?
Yeah.
Wait, do I have to like, go between them?
Like, I can't touch them at all?
Like, is there a hole?
There's a hole.
There's a goal.
Ooh.
Wow!
Whee!
The bakery!
Wow.
Ooh.
Ooh wee.
Oh.
They're speaking.
A little maze.
They're speaking in tongues.
Wait, you're not...
There's tons of holes.
Why aren't you going through them?
Oh.
There we go.
Oh my god.
That's a dead bird.
I don't give a fuck.
Oh, there's a masterpiece on top of the dead bird.
A what?
Oh, yeah.
It's a...
The Phantom of the Opera.
Da da da da da da.
Was that it?
I think so.
And then they're angry.
They're like, you took the mask.
You disturbed the Phantom.
And then they're going to burn down the theater.
Oh, yeah.
That's Lucy.
Is that Lucy's bird?
No.
Lucy's bird was...
Was it?
I don't remember.
I don't remember either.
Oh.
We're back in the chair.
Okay.
Now we can watch more videotapes.
All right.
Time to go back.
Wait.
There was one you put in.
Yeah?
I don't remember which one it was.
Wait.
How did I get crazy?
Oh.
The door.
The bad thing is that I actually don't have any more...
I don't have any more meds.
So I'm forever going little cuckoo.
Well, there's a candle right there.
Yeah.
But it doesn't raise my sanity.
It just makes it so my sanity doesn't go down.
Doesn't go down.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think you raised your sanity in the light though.
Do I?
I think so.
Like it's gone now.
Yeah.
But it just...
It's there to remind me that...
Oh, it does raise my sanity.
Oh, it heals me.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
You're in the light.
Don't leave.
No, I'm just standing next to my candle.
So I can be a little more sane.
I gotta buy myself some scented candles.
All right.
Let's get the...
Prison.
And then pride.
Prison pride.
All right.
I don't think we should have pride.
Prison pride.
Especially when it's privatized.
All right.
PP.
Oh.
We'll do pride first.
Oh, no.
That's a hammer.
Wait.
Which one's this one?
Pride or prison?
Prison.
All right.
Hold on.
Oh, I don't like that.
Ooh.
Oh.
The children yearn for the mines.
That's what you've always wanted.
To the mines we go.
All children want to go in the mines.
Okay.
So, that's the basement.
All right.
And then...
That has to be downstairs again.
We gotta have a hammer.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Probably.
All right.
Pride time.
Woo!
First we mined, then we craft.
Did you see that they were doing, like, a...
The meme edition for the movie watch-alongs?
They're allowing people to, like, go crazy.
Yeah.
I don't think the...
The theater employees are gonna be paid more, though.
I feel like all they have to do is toast it outside.
I think so, too.
Yeah.
Just have it in, like, an open field.
People can mosh.
It'll be fine.
Oh, my God.
A mosh pit?
Where, like, the chicken...
The lava chicken song comes in.
They just start moshing.
It'll be awesome.
The pen lights, I have no idea.
It's, like, a...
Like, a...
Attic or a basement or something.
And then, like, they throw the pen lights out and start doing the...
What is it called?
The...
The little pen light dance that...
Watergate?
Yeah.
They start doing Watergate to, like, lava chicken.
I...
Lava chicken.
Oh, what the fuck is that?
Oh, it's back in the hospital.
That's the hospital.
Yeah.
That's the hospital again.
Yippee!
We left the hospital.
No, did you hear the guy in the video?
He went, yippee!
Oh, okay.
That's the end of...
All right.
So, where is that?
Where's Pride in prison?
Um...
Well, prison, we gotta go back to the basement, like you said.
What about Pride?
Is it also in the basement?
We might as well know if it's in the basement or not.
I'm tired of going in the basement.
I'm tired of the basement.
I'll be where Jesus Christ is.
Oh, actually, Pride is the one that was...
So, that must be the first one you played.
Because it's the one that's on the, um...
Where is it?
The door, right...
The table, right outside this door.
Like the...
That one?
By the front door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's Pride?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Okay, then we'll do prison.
You wanna go to the basement first?
Wait, that's the key to the...
That's the key?
I mean, like, we can do that whenever.
Because it's literally right there.
You know?
Okay.
Yeah, then do...
Then do prison first.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll just take the video out for now.
Are you sure?
Are you sure that's the...
That's the, uh...
Are you sure that's for the...
The Pride?
Are you reading it correctly?
Are you...
That's what he's telling me!
Oh.
The TV turned back.
Oh, I'm getting crazy.
Don't worry.
I have my candle here.
Oh!
The candle can burn out!
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah, that's how...
That's how candles are.
That's...
Okay, Min.
I'm sorry.
But I need a pee.
I didn't get to pee.
I'll be right back.
Guys?
Guys, what?
What?
What is happening?
How long have we been streaming for?
Over an hour and a...
What?
Almost an hour and a half!
Oh, my God.
Please understand.
I don't...
I don't understand.
Yeah.
Send all those...
We were talking about how funny we think these ones are.
The...
The anger...
Angry, angry, angry.
Doki was like, I want to get one made...
Of that emote.
Because it's so funny.
Feels more like a minstream now.
I am!
What would she do without me, huh?
What would she do without me?
I'm holding down the fort here.
I went to get...
I went to get a drink.
And a snack.
And...
I'm holding down the fort here.
Oh, my God.
Very relatable face.
It's kind of creepy.
But I don't hate it.
Oh, my gosh.
You know...
Have you guys ever heard of labubus?
They're like a really big thing right now.
Like, you know how blind boxes are huge?
And...
I keep seeing people being like...
I hate labubus.
They're so ugly.
But I think they're kind of cute.
They remind me of where the wild things are.
So I like them.
The what?
Labubu.
I kind of...
I like them.
And I want to, like, get one.
But apparently, it's like...
You know how people are going insane over Pokemon cards?
People are going insane over these little plushies.
So they're little plush doll keychains of, like...
They look like gremlin creature monsters.
They have these ugly faces and these big old spiky teeth and everything.
Yeah, they're super expensive.
Only because people are scalping them.
Wait, scalping what?
Have you heard of labubus?
Oh, yeah.
I was going to talk about labubus.
Yeah.
They're like such a craze.
I heard about it.
It's like they came out of nowhere.
I've not known where I've been seeing them for around for like a year plus now.
But, like, recently they got so fucking popular.
I know.
That's because the West is behind on...
On the labubu craze now.
Yeah, because, like, it's been in Asia for a long time.
Yeah, yeah.
And then, like, now it's because I've seen them for like, what, two years?
I think like one or two years ago.
So I was like really surprised.
I think they're so cute.
But, like, and I want one.
But I don't want people to be like, oh, she's a labubu girly.
I literally see so many YouTube shorts above, like...
Yeah.
I mean, I saw, like, they're cute.
They're cute.
But, like, I find it funny that now...
I guess, like, they hit their...
Like, they're now, like, a trend or fad now because of all the YouTube shorts and TikToks about it.
So everybody's, like, crazy about it.
I'm a hipster.
I don't want people to be like, oh, she's into labubus.
But it's also, like, it's...
Like, people are going so crazy that it, like, it feels like I would be embarrassed to have one.
Because, like, people are, like, constantly refreshing, like, the website.
Yeah, yeah.
When I was, like, when I was, like, out, like, you know, when I used...
When I went outside for once in my life, other than for my dog, I went to, like, this mall and I went to, like, grab dinner.
And then, like, there were, like, there was, like, two tables in my front that were just talking about labubus.
And they're, like, oh, my God.
I just got, like, the new labubus.
Like, oh, my God.
There's a labubu girl right in front of me.
There's...
I know.
They're in the wild.
They are.
They're really cute.
I just...
I think, like, the community around it is a little bit really fanatic.
It's...
Oh, yeah.
That's why I don't want to...
But also, people, if you have, like, a labubu that somebody wants, people will steal it off.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So I'm just, like, if I get a labubu and then someone steals it, I'll have spent so much money on it.
Yeah.
And I heard, like, there's, like, there's, like, ways to find...
They're, like, this is how you find a fake labubu.
And there's apparently, like, um...
Oh, those are the lafufus.
The lafufus.
Yeah, it was a...
Yeah.
Like, it's called a lafufu.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's funny.
Oh, my God.
All right, let's play a game.
It was gamersups.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so that was what the UPS package was.
All right, let me hydrate real quick.
LaBooBoo.
It's really cool, though, how they...
Did you see how they made it?
So there's, like, apparently the official...
Okay, this is my last solid topic, because it's part of your topic.
Okay.
But, like, LaBooBoo's, they have, like, this special website designed to, like, help people figure out if they're fake or not.
Oh.
And apparently, like, in the LaBooBoo packaging, they would have, like, a special card or whatever to scan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, like, a special QR card just for, like, that particular doll.
So, like, each doll has their own authenticator.
Like, an authenticity certificate that's on the card.
So you scan the card, it'll tell you if it's, like, from that exact LaBooBoo, basically.
Oh, wow, that's crazy.
Yeah, it has, like, your own certificate of authenticity.
So it's just some kind of...
No!
At least you get a product out of it.
I know, right?
You get a physical thing.
And you own it.
Yeah, you own it, too.
So, yeah, I thought it was really...
Yeah, it feels like it just came, like, like, the badge just came out of nowhere.
But it's been around for a while.
It's just been around.
It just got super popular recently.
Well, before that, it was, like, the little sunny angels.
Oh, yeah, yeah, the little naked sun...
The naked angels with the pee-pee out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now it's LaBooBoo.
I don't even know what the little kid angels were called.
The little cupids.
What were they called?
Sunny angels?
Were they actually just called sunny angels?
Yeah, I think so.
It was, like...
Well, now you know why it died.
LaBooBoo is so much...
Oh, yeah!
Before that was TokiDokies, yeah.
I like TokiDokies.
TokiDokies?
Yeah!
You ever know TokiDoki, the unicorns?
Oh, were those popular?
Yeah, they were really popular back then, TokiDokies.
They were like everywhere.
Okay, you're stalling.
Okay, all right, here we go.
Back to the basement.
The basement call us for me.
I feel like I'm gonna die from the tar man soon.
Back to the basement, back to the basement, back to the basement.
All right, where do I go again?
Uh, hold on, I lost the place.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no.
I was on pride instead of prison.
Okay, I got it.
Okay.
So remember, we have to find that wall.
So you got to go get the sledgehammer.
Oh my god, that's stupid.
I think.
Okay.
I don't know.
If I die to the Charmant, then I don't care.
Just quick save.
Why are you suddenly... I did.
No, you can't quick save.
You have to manually save.
I think.
Oh no, it lets me quick save.
Okay.
Okay, we're about to go.
Um... Go to that area.
Oh, turn around.
That way.
That way?
Nope.
Right.
There you go.
That way, yeah.
And go down the stairs.
To the tarp.
Okay.
And then what?
Look around.
See if there's anything different.
I'm still reading.
Step into the long hallway to the left of the tarp.
In there.
I guess.
I'm going crazy again.
Uh-oh.
Turn the lights on.
There you go.
Okay.
What?
Dwayne will look up at a ceiling light.
No?
Um...
What?
Huh?
What do you mean?
How do you figure this out?
Play the prison.
How do you figure this out with the guide?
How do you... I guess you'll be like...
You have to, like, see if anything changes every time.
Go to the area with the mannequin torso behind the blue tarp.
Step into the long hallway to the left of the tarp.
Oh.
What?
That's where we're at, no?
Yeah.
Once you're in the... Try going behind the tarp.
Is there anything there?
No.
Try it.
Okay.
To the left of the tarp.
This is... Is this not the hallway?
Right here.
Nothing here.
Oh.
Nope.
No.
I mean, there's the mannequin.
You did play it.
Keep going deeper?
Keep... Maybe, yeah.
Maybe try going deeper.
Keep going into the mines?
Okay.
Yeah.
Into the mines we go.
Oh.
Wait.
I didn't even need the hammer?
You will.
You will now.
No.
It took my hammer.
Oh.
You have to go get...
They... They took my hammer!
They...
They're like...
Yoink.
It's fine.
Uh...
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
There's the hammer.
They just took my hammer and placed it there, I guess.
Oh.
Yeah.
How kind of them, right?
Oh.
No.
Turn around.
Break the door, right?
Oh.
Never mind.
Scared me.
Oh.
Okay.
Hello.
Hi.
Look into my eyes.
It's so romantic when you choke me.
Oh my gosh.
This is so...
Hold on.
I'm going to read you this entire paragraph.
Okay.
So the lights will start to go out.
Yeah.
Three light bulbs stay on when all the others go off.
The lights that stay on are highly important, both to see and for sanity.
If you remember, the corridors are filled with sockets for light bulbs.
I don't remember that at all.
Oh my gosh.
He's going to start coming.
I hear him.
Oh God.
What?
We don't have any light bulbs.
We didn't pick any up.
Oh my gosh.
They just threw us in here?
No way.
What?
Did it just kill me?
Hold on.
Look at...
Each corridor will have a breakable wall at the end.
So it is important that you have light so you can see where to break the wall.
The wall should be around the center.
Each corridor.
Break the walls, then step inside the room.
Each wall takes three hits to the street.
It won't let me light it up!
Wait.
Can you take one of the light bulbs that's already on?
Like up that one?
No.
Oh, that one?
Oh, I can.
Oh, you can.
Okay.
You're going to go towards the guy?
Did he come from here?
Oh no.
Yeah.
Fuck me, I guess.
Oh, it's like a little game.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Wait, so I had to die the first time?
One, two...
Oh, just kidding.
Three!
What happens here?
Oh.
You get a present.
You beat it up.
I beat it up.
Oh, I'm getting a little crazy.
Son.
Okay.
All right, I think he's going to kill me.
I guess he came from a different...
He comes from a different way this time.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
Me too.
I don't like this.
I don't like this either.
I don't like this at all.
I feel like this little game of light bulb.
Why was the guy even in here?
I feel like this way is difficult.
You just...
You just wanted to be like, Ooga-booga-booga.
Why did he...
No, why did he...
Where did he come from?
Why was he here?
Ooga-booga-booga.
Oh, I see my brain now.
Yes.
Can he get in there?
No?
What am I supposed to do here?
I don't know.
Oh, the...
This one is too high for you to reach.
Oh.
Then what?
Can I go to the last one?
Um, hold on.
Oh my gosh.
There's a stupid special achievement.
I don't care.
Once all the four walls are broken, return to the wall from the exit sign.
And there will be the...
The...
The little mask piece that you need.
I'm gonna die here.
I see my brain.
I don't like it when I see my brain.
Wait, why are there so many hallways?
When did this get so...
Yeah.
Wait, I think you only need to go to the...
Well, it said four.
Yeah, there's one more here.
Oh.
It said four, right?
So I have to break two more.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
I don't like that I can see my brain right now.
Uh, let's just stay in the light for a bit.
Oh, will that help you move?
Wait, how do I...
Drop it?
Wait.
How do I...
What do I do with this?
Oh, no.
You're so helpful.
It doesn't...
It literally doesn't tell you.
It just says break all the walls.
Box.
Just a box.
It's a little box.
I see my brain and I don't like it.
I'm not supposed to see my brain, I feel like.
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Bonk.
Maybe that's why...
Uh, the guy showed up.
Because you could see your brain.
No, I didn't see my brain, though, that time.
Uh...
Oh, there's people watching me here.
But I'm going crazy looking at it.
Yeah.
Maybe don't look at it, then.
But they call for me.
Okay.
So you broke them?
Yeah, so I go...
I should be allowed to go through, right?
I suppose.
So turn to the wall with the exit sign and there will be a miracle.
Oh, yeah, look.
See?
It's more breakable.
Ah, yeah, it's there.
There you go.
Ooh, why is it so wet all of a sudden?
Oh!
And then I get to leave!
Yippee!
Okay.
Alright, we got another one.
Well, that wasn't bad.
That one wasn't bad.
Except for the time that guy was like, Fuck you.
Why was he there?
Yeah.
Oh, did you see that?
It returned to normal.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I need to find a candle.
Or some light.
Just...
No, I think...
You can stand in the light.
It says like, I have to stand in candle area, though.
Oh.
What just happened?
They closed the door on me.
Rude!
Don't worry.
Your candle's about to go out.
I'm worrying.
It's not getting any lighter.
Oh.
Wait, it is!
Why is...
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Why is the music so...
I don't like that.
Oh.
Oh!
Uh.
Oh my god.
Don't move it so fast.
Just keep it there.
Oh, I don't think that...
I don't think holding it...
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Okay.
I still see my brain.
That's not good.
I still...
I still see my brain right now.
That's...
That's not good.
All right.
I'm putting the next two tapes.
Wait, no.
We didn't do the other one.
Yeah, but the other one's right here.
We could do that one every.
Okay, all right.
You're right.
Yeah, so we should do the ones that are like...
I keep accidentally blowing the candles.
Oops.
Okay, a difference.
What if I'm like watching the video...
And then the guy just starts coming off with the ceiling?
Why is your...
Why is your sanity going so down?
I don't know.
I don't like it.
Oh, there's a door.
It feels like it's like really bad.
Yeah.
There's a door with keys.
It's a nudist beach.
Okay.
Oh!
I don't want to see the naked people.
Okay, there's paintings.
Paintings.
Oh.
Spiral stairs.
What is this?
A lighthouse?
It's Europe.
Europe?
Yeah, there's a nudist beach.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
There's multiple things.
Wait, which one do we go to?
I don't know.
They showed us four different locations.
Oh, this table show a chain door in several places on the wall for picture frames.
Yeah.
Oh, so we have to find picture frames.
God damn it.
Wait, the final set of images show you the locations for each collectible item that you'll need to complete this tape adventure.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, we're doing that next time.
We're doing that the other time.
No, I think this one will be long.
I think we should do it now.
Okay.
Don't put in another one.
Just keep this one on, you know?
Okay, but what if the other one's easy?
I mean, I guess.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm going to check the other one.
Okay.
Let's do...
Negligence.
How is my sanity going down?
I'm next to the candle.
Who's going ooga-booga-booga?
Okay, this is negligence.
Negligence.
Oh, is that not where we are?
No, it's not.
No, that's the basement.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Again, it's like everything's the basement, apparently.
Oh, my God.
It all happens in the basement.
I'm looking for negligence.
Okay, you're still dancing.
It has not stopped dancing.
Oh, wait, where's this?
This is the hospital.
How do we get to the hospital?
From the basement.
Okay, but how do we...
Whoa, look at him, girl.
Whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Yep.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, but how do we get there?
Go to the TV room in the basement.
Yeah, but how do we get there from...
Oh, your brain's gone.
My brain's gone.
Yippee, empty-minded, as I've always wanted.
All right, back to the basement I go.
Okay.
To the TV room.
It's this way.
No.
Oh, it's the other way.
The TV room?
Right there.
Okay, and then what do we do?
Step into the area with the TV and the sofa.
Check the pictures on the wall besides the sofa.
And take the rec...
Oh.
Take that.
Okay.
And then play it.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
I hope they play crazy frog.
Oh, pew, pew, pew, pew.
I am a gummy bear.
You are a gummy bear, but...
Oh, hey, it's a nice shopping mall.
Let's go.
Oh, we're going shopping.
You know, someone made...
There's, like, a guy who's, like, incredibly obsessed with the gummy bear song where they pre...
They made their own render of the gummy bear song, but it made it look like it was made in 2025.
What?
Yeah.
They, like, re-rendered...
They, like, made their own gummy bear render.
This guy is so loud.
Oh, I'm an alcoholic.
Let's go!
Crack beer!
Nothing bad happens to alcoholics.
Wait.
Just put them in your...
Put them in your...
Oh, you're right.
Oh, it's a special price.
Yeah, take them, take them.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, my God.
Special price?
What a steal.
No cheese, no soup, no tomatoes.
Beer only.
Beer, beer, beer.
Beer, beer.
Nothing but beer.
Beer o'clock.
What they don't know, it says always beer o'clock.
Get a car.
No, I can fit, like, two more.
I don't have kids.
Let's go.
Buy us chocolate, Doki.
We got all your needs for food, especially drinks.
Yippee.
Beer, beer, beer.
Yeah, beer would be nice.
Yeah, do you think we need more?
Oh, do you think...
I think we need more beer.
Oh, my God.
Please, I can fit two more.
One for the...
We should have held off for some beer.
Yeah, we should...
Yeah.
I told you we should have got that box of beers.
We could have got this box of beers.
Yeah, we should have gotten that box of beers.
Yeah.
We need more.
We got arms.
We can put it on the side of our arms.
Oh, it's cheap today.
Only today, too.
Only today.
What a bargain.
Yeah, there's no reason not to.
Look at that.
Maybe two.
Maybe three.
Don't worry.
Five.
One for evening, one for later tonight, and one for midnight.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Sir, I know.
I got it.
I have problems.
I already know.
Two beers in the morning?
I wondered.
For your cereal.
Beer cereal?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, beer.
The best time to start my...
The beer.
Best time to start your morning.
That's...
What's it?
Nothing.
If you're...
If you're drunk in the morning, there's zero consequences.
Nothing better than waking up with a beer in your cup.
Beautiful.
Did you just come up with that yourself?
Just then?
It's like a...
Isn't that Folgers?
There's like a coffee brand in the US.
What?
That's like...
If you want...
Or nothing better than waking up and having...
Fol...
Folgers...
...sures in your cup.
Time to drink.
Oh, my God.
Don't really say...
One in the m...
One or two in the morning.
Yeah.
We got a special price.
Don't feel guilty.
Yeah.
Can't let it have you be inspired.
What a day.
Okay, this might actually be the easiest one.
All you had to do was...
Grab beer and drink it.
Daddy?
Oh, my God.
Little Sarah wants a story.
And once upon a time...
Daddy bought lots of beer.
Lots of funny juice.
And now he's pretty funny.
Are you pressing this to drink?
LB to drink?
My daughter talks to me...
So I have to drink now.
I have a bedtime story.
Are you just going to ignore her?
What?
Time to drink.
You don't talk.
You don't sleep in the bedroom.
You don't get out at all.
You just don't care.
Do you?
We signed nothing to have us not care.
Oh, my God.
You're right.
Sorry.
I signed a contract with a crow.
Oh, the walls are melting.
The walls are melting.
Croaky told me to do it.
I didn't read the contract fully.
Sorry.
I checked the time.
It's a beer o'clock.
Dwayne, it's always beer o'clock.
Does he just not...
Does he just like...
He just drinks.
Yeah, he just drinks and...
And watches TV.
Just another day.
Don't worry.
My wife's just going through some phase right now.
Like, I think drunk people...
Like, you know...
Drunk people at least will talk to you.
I don't know.
Yeah.
The walls are kind of crazy.
Oh.
You have too much to drink.
You have too much?
Oh, I'm choking.
From what?
Oh, from glass.
Whoops.
God, check...
It's like when you...
During the Halloween, you all check your candy.
There's glass in it.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Remember, check your beer.
There's glass in it.
Check your beer.
Right.
That was that one.
Oh, that one.
That was so easy.
Yeah, and they put me back in the TV room, too.
No, they're going to send you back...
To a different place.
Oh.
Oh, can you see anything?
Oh, okay.
Where do I go?
Oh.
I'm hungover right now.
Yeah.
Oh, they did put you back in there.
Never mind.
You're right.
Yeah.
My TV room is a little crazy right now.
It's a little messed up now.
Can you, like, turn the lights on?
Why is it so...
I'm not okay.
Why is it so blurry in here?
Can I, like, be sober?
Yeah.
How do I watch?
Wait, no.
This room is...
Wait.
How do I get out of this room?
Do I close it and it'll turn back to normal?
Oh, maybe, yeah.
Oh.
No, my room's fucked.
No.
Maybe just keep going somewhere else.
I don't know.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, now it's okay.
Oh, my game crashed.
No way.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
No way.
Oh, my game.
No.
It had to have saved.
It had to have saved after that.
It, like, closed the door on me and then it crashed.
Oh.
No.
Okay.
All right.
We know what to do.
We just gotta grab Beers.
Doors.
No, it's probably saved after you got the piece, I imagine.
I feel like...
I don't know.
Oh, I...
They said you have to manually save now throughout the...
This chapter.
So, they don't auto-save anymore.
Oh.
No.
We'll find out.
Oh, my God.
Wait, no.
Oh, it did.
It saved the moment it closed the door.
Yay.
Oh, see?
See?
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know where I'm at, though.
No, the candle's still here, though.
Wait.
Is that my candle?
I could be.
I don't know.
You could go to the progress room, maybe, and see.
That's true.
Because that's where the things have been showing up.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
Yeah.
I could check.
How many did we get, though?
Four?
All right.
Let's see.
I can't remember.
I don't know.
Oh, look at all the beers I've been drinking.
Oh, this is the place where I've been drinking.
Is that romantic?
Oh, yeah.
Look how many beers there are.
Does this place raise my sanity?
Okay, we have three.
Wait, we have four.
Did we do four already?
That's why I said four.
I think it's four.
Oh, yeah.
Four.
Yeah, we're missing three.
Is that correct?
That sounds right.
All right.
So, what was the one that was really long?
It was the painting one.
Yeah, but I don't...
Which was it called?
It's in my hand, so I can grab the other two now.
And then we'll do the painting one there at, like, second last.
Because that shit looks long.
Okay.
We can do pride.
Well, pride is the one by the door.
Yeah, so that one we'll do the very last last.
Because then we get that done right up.
I'm not crazy.
Oh, my candle's gone.
You're not crazy?
Oh, yes, you are.
Yeah, yes, you are.
Oh, wait.
How about two?
Oh, that's what...
Can you share the game?
Sorry, I was watching through the stream.
I was like...
I was like, why am I so beloved?
I'm not behind.
Wait, did I not?
Yeah, no, I'm sharing it right now.
You're not seeing it?
I bet I'm getting paused.
Okay, I'll reshare it.
Yeah.
All right.
Massage.
Don't worry.
I'll give you even lower quality.
Wait, why isn't it...
Oh, there we go.
Watch the stream.
Okay, I'll give that 1080.
You don't need 14, 480p.
Yeah, whatever.
Okay, fine.
Wait, but I only have one tape left.
But we have two that you...
Oh, we have two.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I can't...
Sorry, I can't count.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we got...
We did that.
Wait.
I think this one...
Oh, no.
We got addictions.
Oh, wait.
That's...
Indifference we didn't do.
We need to do...
Okay, next one is addiction.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Stop.
Discord.
You suck now.
Yeah, because the CEO resigned and it got bought by...
What was it?
The Blizzard CEO?
Yeah, something like that.
That's the new CEO now.
All right.
Okay.
Where's that?
Oh, that's the parents' bedroom.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
It went to the market, too.
It went to the stock market.
Yeah, they opened up.
Now, Discord is controlled by 80-year-old men.
Good luck.
Guys, we still have TeamSpeak.
Don't...
We can always go back to TeamSpeak.
Oh, 7, Discord.
Wait.
What do we do?
This is in the parents' bedroom.
Yeah, I think we just go up there.
Yeah, go upstairs.
Step into the parents' bedroom.
And, yeah.
You'll go.
The radio's been on.
Oh, little cuckoo.
Nah.
All right.
That hole in the ground?
Wait.
There's a hole in the ground.
Where did my bed go?
You sold it for beer.
Oh.
The deals were too good.
Hello.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
I did not like that.
Beer?
Is that really beer?
Yeah.
My wife.
Oh, you don't have a lot.
Oh.
Wait.
Use the light.
I want to see what it looks like with the lighter.
It's beer.
Oh, it really is beer.
My beautiful wife.
Oh, wow.
I'll never betray you.
More beer.
I've been waiting for you for quite some time now.
All right.
You're my friend, aren't you?
Yeah.
Is that a plague doctor's mask?
Yeah, it is.
What a look you have.
Are you tired somehow?
I getcha.
It's hard.
Oh, can I drink?
Oh, nice.
I can drink.
Nice.
I do not want to talk to...
I do not want to listen to you.
And I'm glad you came along.
More beer.
We're here to talk about you, right?
Yeah, me.
Can I keep drinking?
I don't have a problem.
I don't need him to tell me to do it.
I have no control of my life.
Dwayne.
Of course.
There's no mystery here.
But I can see that you are wondering if this is real after all.
I can assure you...
We're not real.
Although this might not reassure...
We're anime.
That it is...
I'm real...
Anime.
She's a ghost.
You don't even know she's right behind you right now.
No, no.
Don't look at me like that.
I'm on your side, Dwayne.
We've been friends for so long after all.
Yeah, that's my best friend.
That's my best friend.
Yeah.
No, he's my best friend.
He was my friend.
Ice Monkey is my best friend.
Wait, no.
Wait.
Can we trade?
Ice Monkey is a better friend.
No, you already said this guy is your best friend.
Yeah, but I can't multiple best friends.
No, you can't prioritize all of them equally.
Okay, that's true.
But...
But I can...
Oh, take a sip.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I'll take a sip.
Yeah, you don't have to tell me.
I wanted a drink a while ago.
I bet my best friend can beat up your best friend.
If you want me to help you, I've got to know something.
I doubt it.
My best friend is really...
Oh.
No?
Well, what could be the reason behind all that drinking and drugging?
Wait, I do drugging too?
Yeah.
What?
Oh, I don't know what...
When?
I thought you were just an alcoholic.
I...
Maybe it's the pills.
I don't know.
Whoa.
Yeah, you took all your pills, remember, Doki?
Oh, yeah.
That's the drugging.
I took all of them.
Oh, take a sip.
Oh, yeah.
Sure.
Drink a little of this wonderful poison.
It'll do you real good.
Yay.
Drinking away my problems.
See, I knew doing this one was easier than the fucking Easter hunt.
I still see them.
He lied.
Yeah.
Do you need to drink another one?
Oh, that drink until they're gone?
Cheers.
Yippee.
How much am I drinking?
Because there's still some...
Oh, they're gone.
See?
Oh, yeah, they're gone.
I know it.
You know you can always rely on this to get you back on track, don't you?
Yeah.
Yeah, see, my best friend makes...
Gives me free alcohol.
What the fuck does Ice Monkey do?
I'm telling Ice Monkey you said that.
Wait, don't tell him that.
Don't...
I'm calling him and be like, Jake, don't believe it.
I would never insult you.
Wait, wait, it's just a joke.
It's just a joke.
He meant nothing to me.
It's Ice Monkey all the way.
Wait, did you tell me to drink?
I don't know.
I'm just gonna drink anyway.
I just drink anyway.
Cheers.
I was too busy thinking of him.
Ice Monkey.
Ice Monkey is the real cure to our poison.
Oh, another sip.
He cures all depression.
You guys...
Masked man, your cup's looking a little empty.
You want some?
Yeah, you want some?
You want some more?
I want a drink by myself.
I'll pour it on the TV.
No, Dwayne, will you fucking tell me who you are?
I'm Dwayne.
The Rock Johnson.
Takes another sip.
We're so nonchalant.
Yeah, it's like, who are you?
I'm Dwayne.
Hi, I'm Paul.
Oh, there it is.
There's the glass.
Nice, easy.
Nice.
Back-to-back drinking simulator.
Good for my health.
All right, two more.
All right.
Yippee.
Oh, I'm very drunk right now.
Maybe you should have done those later.
Yeah.
How are you going to walk up the ladder?
That's a good question.
Okay, you got this.
Yeah, I got this.
You're only drunk in the game, doggie.
Slow and steady.
Oh, the bed is back.
Yippee.
All right.
Now we have the last two.
The little mini Easter hunk downstairs.
Why did they make that one so hard?
What one was that?
What was that one called?
Oh, let's see.
Let me check.
I think it's this one.
Indifference?
Is it indifference?
No, actually, it should be this one.
Pride.
It was pride.
No.
No, pride is the one that's right here by the front door.
No, it's not prison.
We did that one.
Oh, then it should be indifference then.
Okay, it's indifference.
We got one of them eventually.
I think you should put the indifference tape in the thing so we can, like, refer back to it.
No, I mean, like, it doesn't matter.
Like, oh, wait.
Oh, you want to see what it is?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Store.
You could probably also get rid of the other ones if you wanted.
Well, I'm putting all of them.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
I mean, this is the last.
Oh, wait.
Whoops.
Not, like, negligence.
All right.
Okay.
Yeah, the one time I should be drinking, I can't drink.
I know, right?
I can't immerse myself.
How am I getting crazy?
I'm just putting tapes on the TV.
Okay, I'll just put everything else.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
It shows the door.
Yeah, yeah.
Silent Hill 4.
Uh-huh.
And then nudist beach.
God, they really wanted to focus on that.
Oh, my God.
Show us the next scene.
Okay, there's the paintings.
It's five paintings?
Six paintings?
Six paintings.
Okay.
But where do we put the paintings?
So, I think what we do is we...
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
There was a spiral staircase.
Then what?
Where's that?
Okay, I know where that is.
And then that's the parents' room.
Parents' room.
Yeah.
Or the little girls.
I don't know three of this area.
Yeah.
What is that?
Or that's the TV room.
Okay, well, I just go to the...
Or go to the ones that we do know.
Okay.
Parents' room.
Are you sure it was the parents and not the little girls?
No.
We can watch it again.
No, it's so long!
Just go, just go.
We can go to either one.
It doesn't matter.
I am not sure.
I'm never sure.
That's my secret.
Just try the parents.
No, I think...
I think it was the...
Oh, wait.
No, because...
Wasn't the dresser old?
This one, right?
Yeah, right there.
Yeah.
It's right here.
Oh, that.
Yeah.
Okay, we got that.
Where is it placed?
Oh, it's in my inventory.
Okay, and then where?
Okay.
What was the first one that we saw?
I don't remember.
I'm going back downstairs.
Wait, there's another lighter.
When did I drop this?
Oh.
All right.
Time to watch our favorite video.
Okay, hold on.
All right.
There's the door.
Yeah.
And then it's going to show us naked people.
Oh, the freezer.
Yeah.
Okay, but is there anything like up top?
Like here before I go back downstairs though?
The freezer?
Is it downstairs?
Yeah, there was a freezer.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
The freezer.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
And there was a...
I think the chair is in the attic, no?
Oh, is that the progress room?
What progress?
No?
Wait.
No, the attic?
The one where...
Oh, the...
No, I don't...
I don't think there's one in the attic.
I think that was the...
Okay, where the fuck is that?
What is that?
Okay, there's the freezer.
Okay, the freezer.
That's the parents room with that one.
Yeah.
That's...
No, yeah, see, there's got...
There's Mary.
That's the attic.
I don't know where that one is.
That's downstairs.
That's the basement.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, so we know two of them.
Don't worry, I'm dual wielding.
Freezer and...
Progress room, is what we know.
Yeah, freezer and progress room.
It's bad that I used up all the candles right away.
I did not realize that they...
Did you guys know that candles can burn out?
Wow, Doki not realizing something!
I learned something new today.
Wait, is it the snow?
Where's the...
It was by the chair.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay!
Alright, what's next?
There was the freezer.
Oh, the freezer, yeah.
And then there's...
But then we should figure out where the other ones are before we go back.
There was another one by a plant.
Where's the plant?
It was like in a hallway with a plant.
Oh wait, maybe here?
I don't know.
There's no paintings here.
Well, it's just a frame.
It's not a painting.
Yeah, but it should be like...
Seeable.
I should be able to take...
Yeah, I should be able to take one of the candles into Jesus' room.
I know, that...
Yeah.
Yeah, I agree.
Quick save.
I'm quick...
Yeah, that's right.
I'm quick saving.
She save scumming?
Alright, yeah.
That's...
It's not save scumming if I don't quick load it every time.
Alright.
Yeah, okay.
Alright, so...
Is there...
Is there anything else?
Okay, we got two of...
It's five, right?
So we know where...
We need to figure out what the last one...
Six of them?
So we need to figure out what the last two are.
Is those the last two we don't know?
Also, where the fuck do we put these paintings?
What?
The dark ones are tough.
Yeah.
I can't see them at all.
I don't know where they are.
Like...
Okay, there's the spiral room.
Okay.
Hello, little boy.
Do you know where the...
Get out of the way, baby.
I don't know what that is at all.
I don't know what that is.
Chat, what is that?
What is that?
Okay, we got that one.
We got that one.
I don't know what that one is.
Is that the boiler room maybe?
It could be the boiler room.
But that one...
That one is downstairs.
That's the basement.
I know that one's the basement.
I don't know where...
Well, then you know two that are in the basement, so go get them.
Oh, it's the TV.
The downstairs TV?
They said that's the downstairs TV.
Okay, then all three of them is in the basement.
Okay.
Electric room outside of the...
Mmm...
So down this way?
Oh, there's another candle.
Oh, nice.
It's here, right?
Yeah, right here.
Oh, right here is the freezer.
Wait, wait, wait, there's one here.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there's that one.
Okay.
And then where's the other one?
So is that the electric room?
Let's try the electric room.
Doesn't hurt to try again.
Oh, maybe.
Because it's...
I don't see anything here.
I don't see anything.
I don't either.
Try your lighter.
Turn on your light.
What if the...
Go back in with the lighter.
What if the scary man shows up?
Well, you quicksaved.
It's fine.
What if he shows up?
That doesn't...
Like, he's still gonna kill me.
Yeah, but it's fine.
Opposite of laundry?
Guys, where's the laundry?
I don't...
The laundry.
And the area with chairs opposite of the laundry.
The laundry was upstairs, no?
Wait.
Electronic room?
Where's the electronic?
That's the...
Electronic room?
What?
Here, I'm just gonna read the wiki.
What is it?
There is one in the breaker room.
There is one in here.
I'm blind.
Wait, what if I...
There's a cardboard box and it's leaning on top of it.
Wait.
I'm trying to figure out how to put this.
There we go.
Okay.
Where?
Look down more?
Is it leaning against the box?
Where?
Against the cardboard box.
Check behind the door?
No.
It says...
We're looking at the right one?
Step into the breaker room.
The room to the right as you step out of the freezer room.
And take the frame leaning against the left side of the cardboard box directly ahead.
There's some black trash bags near the box.
I'm not blind.
Sir, go...
Look at the box from straight like you're walking into the room.
Maybe.
That will help.
And use your lighter.
So, no.
Not against...
It's by the cardboard boxes!
How many times do I have to say box?
There's 20 of them!
Okay, we'll keep looking!
Do you see it?
I can't see shit because I have 1080p!
Okay, 1080p is actually pretty decent for some people in the world, okay?
So, people are lucky to even get like 9, like 7, 7, 720p.
Why aren't you looking down?
I'm looking at the boxes!
There's like 3 boxes!
How many more boxes do you want me to look at?
Oh.
He opened the door.
That's rude.
You did?
No, he did.
Oh.
He might be coming.
Whoops.
Um...
Wait, I don't see anything.
Are you sure?
It says in the room with the...
With the...
With the breaker.
I don't know what else to tell you.
Guys, is she like lying?
I'm literally looking at all the boxes that I could physically look at.
No way, Mint never lies.
Then where are the frames?
It's just one frame.
Okay, Miss Know-It-All.
Actually...
Actually, it's just one frame.
Where is it?
Where is your stupid one frame?
Leaning against the left side of a cardboard box directly ahead.
There are some black trash bags near the box.
The last frame...
Wait.
What?
Oh, never mind.
No.
What?
No, it's in here.
Yeah.
Clearly, it's not.
Clearly, it's not in here.
It's in here.
Clearly, someone is lying.
Clearly, I can't see anything in here.
That implies there's a frame.
Okay.
I don't think you have to get them in a certain order.
I don't think so either.
I got all of them at random order.
Yeah.
I don't...
I don't know.
Okay, pull up a video.
A video?
Pull up a video just to see where the stupid frame is!
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right.
Just that particular frame!
Wait, someone was like, I see it.
Where do you see this frame?
I think they're...
Wait!
I think...
I think they're lying.
I swear to God, it was never in this room.
I swear to fucking God.
It says...
Do you want me to screen cap what I see in the guide?
No, no, no, no.
Screen cap the video and...
Hold on.
I'm like on top of the boxes now.
We're on indifference, right?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Okay, hold on.
This one's really long, so I have to...
It's in between the boxes?
Which boxes?
Oh, is it that right there?
Where?
In between the boxes?
You're just making shit up!
Okay, hold on.
I'm watching them.
I saw them get the first frame.
Okay, I saw them get this frame.
Oh, I know where that one is.
It's by the cat clock.
Okay.
Which is that one?
Was it never here?
Okay, hold on.
No, no, no.
Was it never here?
I'm watching.
Okay, I'm watching.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's like...
Right there.
It's...
They just walk in and go bloop.
Okay.
Where is it?
I'm looking at it!
Did we already grab it?
Check how many you have.
I have these.
Three.
Parents?
Okay, click...
Okay.
Click on...
Click on the...
The box...
That is like...
Okay, your...
Your cursor...
Okay, down a little.
Just click in between the boxes.
Not that one.
Yeah, like in between these ones.
There's nothing.
I'm clicking my heart out.
I'm gonna send you...
I'm gonna send you the timestamp, okay?
There's nothing.
I swear to god.
Did that painting glitch out?
I'm gonna send you the timestamp.
I...
Where is this?
Look at this.
Where...
Okay, I'm looking at it.
She literally just goes...
Where is that painting?
I don't see it.
Where is that?
What is that?
We just went...
I can't see it.
Why is that not here with us?
Like...
There's nothing here.
I'm...
Yeah, there really isn't.
Where did our painting go?
Where is it?
It's not where it shows it in the video.
Did you somehow accidentally pick it?
It's right here.
When did I pick that painting up?
It's my very...
Oh, it's the very first thing I picked up.
Because it was the first video we watched.
I forgot.
I forgot we watched that.
That was our first video we watched.
And that was the very first painting we picked up where we discovered this room.
I...
Everyone spam that angry guy emoji.
Everyone...
What?
I...
I forgot about it.
Ba-ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Only one person's mad here, chat's like, lol.
No, no, no.
No, no, no!
Okay, anyway, so...
It was never in you!
Oh my god, Minj, do you like to be?
You don't even remember!
You weren't there on stream when I picked it up the very first time!
Go to the storage room.
You did it.
You forgot about this painting too.
It wasn't just me.
All I'm saying is you forgot.
I hope he comes and grabs your ass.
No, stop.
I hope the tar man comes.
No, no, tar man.
The tar man cometh.
Tar man.
Ah.
Did you see like someone did a marriage proposal with that?
Yes.
I just see that.
So good.
Yeah, where do I go next?
I don't know.
You sequins broke.
Hold on.
Oh, um.
Uh.
You can go upstairs to the cat clock.
There's one there.
All right.
Upstairs time.
Is that... The last one, I think, is the cat clock one.
Okay, so it's all the way back here.
Champion of the tar.
Uh.
Turn around.
Nope.
Don't.
Uh.
Turn around.
Walk.
I'm walking.
Turn to your right.
Oh, sorry.
You're left.
Okay.
Someone doesn't know.
Turn to your left.
There it is.
On the wall.
Up.
There it is.
This one?
Which one?
That's the light.
No, I saw it in the video.
What?
Uh.
There's supposed to be a one around here.
Hold on.
I have one, two, three, four, five.
I have five on me.
Hold on.
One.
Two.
Hold on.
Let me get the...
Did you choose the wrong wall?
Maybe.
Uh.
There's also one...
Oh, gosh.
Where is it?
Oh, no.
It's not there.
Oh.
Just kidding.
Let's get this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is the last one?
On the ground by the chair.
Which chair?
There's so many chairs.
This guy loves chairs.
I do love chairs.
Come on.
Come on, Blay.
Yes, but also...
I looked through all the chairs.
The tar man cometh.
No tar man, don't come over.
I don't wanna pay the toll.
Okay, hold on.
So this one is the closet.
The first one is the closet.
Second one is...
Oh, wait.
I think I'm a little bit off.
Oh.
Take the top picture of the potted plant on the small table.
Wait, huh?
What?
No.
I think I'm in the wrong spot.
I was like, what do you mean?
Oh, maybe it's over by the potted plant.
Try over that...
No, try up the stairs.
Is that any of those?
No.
You're confusing me, Mint.
You're confusing me.
Go back to the video.
Oh my god.
You can't go back to the video.
I'm controlling the game.
No.
You go to the video in the living room so we can see.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, I know where it is.
Sorry.
Go back.
I was right...
Kind of.
Turn around.
Okay.
What the...
Why is the question mark there?
Oh, it's the tar man.
You interact.
Yeah.
Go into the room right there on your left.
And there.
See?
We...
Oh my god.
Up...
The...
That one.
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Yeah.
All right.
And then what do we do with the paintings?
Um...
Where do we go?
Take all the strange frames with you over to the stairs that go up to the kitchen stairway.
Go up to the kitchen stairway?
Okay.
And then what?
Like, uh...
The one in the basement.
Remember?
Like that...
That stairway in the basement that you have to go to?
This one?
This the kitchen?
There's the kitchen here.
Uh...
Maybe you can go to it from...
The other way.
Like, uh...
You know.
Yeah.
Right in there.
He's not helping.
No, no.
Turn around.
Go through that door.
No.
There's another one here.
This kitchen stairway?
Should be, yeah.
Okay.
So there...
It says that there should be some place to place the frames at.
Oh, I think you can s...
Is it like...
There?
Before getting on the stairs, move over the wall and...
Ugh!
There are marks on the wall where frames should go.
It says!
Before you get on the stairs, in the basement!
There's no frames anywhere.
I say the basement and she keeps going upstairs, you guys.
Okay.
I'm in the basement.
Is it this?
Is that...
Are those the markings?
Is that supposed to represent the painting?
Where the paintings go?
No.
That's the...
Other side.
On that side, maybe?
Oh.
No.
No, this is the...
Uh-oh.
It's fine.
I have multiple letters.
No.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna say...
I'm gonna just read it out for you, word for word.
Okay.
How's that gonna help me?
Because maybe you can have a thought, for once.
I don't...
But I'm not...
I'm not what?
I don't know how to have independent thought.
Take all the frames with you over to the stairs that go up to the kitchen...
Slash stairway.
And before getting on the stairs, move over to the wall...
To the right of the bottom of the stairs in the basement.
There are marks on the wall where some frames should go.
What?
So go back to where we were.
Where I told you to go.
What?
That makes no sense.
Where are you going?
Turn around!
Just go in the basement!
This is...
This is the basement.
Why are you going upstairs?
We gotta stay in the downstairs.
I'm downstairs!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Why do you want me to go?!
In here!
Go back.
Yes.
Okay.
It's somewhere around here.
Can you move anything?
Like, uh...
It says I can't use it!
I don't know where it is, where it goes.
I'm literally just telling you where it tells me though.
Oh my god.
I don't know!
Yeah, can you like interact with the wall?
Maybe can you move?
No, no, no, I can't!
I'm touching everything!
God, you're so... You're a bad guy!
I didn't stop it!
Try moving that plank of wood.
Can you move that plank of wood?
No!
No, I'm touching everything!
What about that?
It's a candle!
I'll put a candle there.
Yeah, put a candle there.
While we figure this out!
Turn right there.
You can't put anything on the wall right there.
On the other side of the wall.
Like, behind you.
No.
Where you put the candle at?
The correct wall is striped.
What?
Did we see a striped wall?
I don't know.
I'm so lost.
Where do we go?
The other stairs?
What other stairs are there?
The other one?
I wanted to go down!
You yelled at me!
You're like, no, it's not that one.
This one!
Oh, yeah, here.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
You yelled at me for this!
Oh, my God.
You're like, it's not this one, Doki!
Go back to the other stairs!
It's safe!
Go back to the other stairs, Doki!
It's not that one!
It's a bad guide, everybody!
Everybody is a bad guide!
I was like, is it this one?
They're like, no!
Go back to the other one!
I didn't know!
Okay, to be fair, I didn't know that one led to the kitchen.
I didn't know that would lead to the kitchen.
Oh, take that pill.
Oh, take that funny pill.
Which one will you take?
Wait, you can take the red pill or you take the blue pill.
Which pill will you... Oh, wait.
Remember when you said I'm also a druggie?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you have to take all of them.
Proving them right.
Let's go.
I don't have a problem.
Life just made me this way.
All right.
Finally, I won't hear her voice anymore.
Green pill.
Take the green pill.
Doki, can you hear me?
Doki, it's the other wall.
Doki, Doki, you have to listen to me.
Finally, the voices I got.
Thank God.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
That's where chat goes.
Goodbye, chat.
All right.
Open the door.
Hey, why can't I go through?
The meds don't work anymore.
No!
I hear her!
They lied!
And I can't even save!
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Oh, hey, he's painting.
That is so bad.
He's an artist.
Oh.
Okay.
Was that supposed to be scary?
Maybe.
Oh, what's this?
It's just water.
Drink the water.
I can't.
He won't let me drink the water.
No.
What does it let you do?
Nothing?
Nothing.
I can look at the water.
Okay.
Continue onward, I guess.
He's not done with his art.
No peeking.
Oh.
Oh, it's just pills.
More pills.
Pills you.
Pills here.
All right.
Okay.
Last door.
Oh, it's a fake door.
Just kidding.
Oh, okay.
I like how one door is just water.
Stay hydrated.
Oh, grief.
Solace.
Depression.
Anxiety.
Oh, hey, I'm trauma dumping.
Give me a sec.
One moment.
Let me tell you guys everything.
Let me tell you guys all the baggage I have.
That's why I'm a VTuber.
Soul.
What?
Soulless.
Hatred.
Depression.
Sorry.
Hatred.
So, when I was a kid...
Oh, my God.
What's happening?
Is everything okay?
What's going on?
They're in the mines.
Oh, my God.
Look, guys.
Aren't you all great to be mining?
We're mining and crafting.
That's Minecraft.
Mining and crafting.
What about that guy?
Whoa.
He's sniffing out the mines.
He's sniffing out the diamonds right now.
Yeah, he can smell diamonds.
Yeah, you know how, like, pigs who can smell truffles?
Oh.
He's smelling the diamonds right now.
This guy just has trauma.
Like, I saw the Minecraft movie and got chicken jockeyed.
Yeah.
He's like, no.
Not chicken jockey.
He's, like, one of the theater workers.
Like, he hears chicken jockey for the thousandth time and that's his breaking point.
They keep saying chicken jockey, but I don't understand.
Why is it funny?
Flint and steel.
Oh, I need both hands.
Okay.
Let me put my lighter away, apparently.
Whoa.
Row.
We're on the river sticks.
Row, row, row, your boat.
Your boat.
Gently down the stream.
Merrily, merrily.
Wait, how does it go again?
Life is but a dream.
I think that's how it is.
I forgot.
It's been a while since I sang that song.
Do you go to the red, or where do you go?
Oh, look.
She's holding his TV for him.
What a good way.
Oh, wow.
He's watching TV in the water.
What a good...
Drop the TV.
That should be us.
I'll be the one holding the TV.
He is having a hoot and a holler.
Oh, my God.
She's only wearing her bra, too.
It's like that ninja tweet where like...
Oh, yeah, but she's wearing a bra.
You know that ninja tweet where like, I'm living the life.
My wife just came in without a bra giving me a sandwich.
What?
Hey, you never saw that tweet?
No.
I don't think so.
Yeah, like ninja was like, I'm living the good life.
My wife just came in without a bra giving me a sandwich.
As like, um, and that was like a...
And like, they're like, I'm here to own the haters.
Oh.
Alright.
What?
We're just watching this guy.
Is this YouTube friendly?
I don't know.
Don't worry about it.
I've been watching this like, last...
For a while now.
I was like, did I be watching that?
Do you go towards the big red brain?
Where do you go?
Oh, over here.
Oh, there is a big...
Oh, it's like an apple.
Apple.
Oh, is that what that is?
Yeah.
It's, it's Defno.
Oh, yeah.
Defno.
Oh, it's Persona!
He's, he's doing Persona!
Persona!
He's summoning his like, sand or whatever it's called.
His stand.
I don't know.
I've never played Persona.
Can you tell I've never played Persona before?
I can't get up the stairs.
Oh, there it is.
It like, blocked me a little.
It's called a Persona.
Wait, is that why the game is called Persona?
You didn't even know, Mint.
You didn't know.
I've never played Persona.
Yeah, see?
Mint is also...
But I know it's not called a stand.
I know that.
Mint also didn't know.
I know it's not a stand.
She's part of the problem.
Definitely not part of the solution.
Yeah.
This game cannot save manually if needed.
Oh, it's my best friend.
I was waiting for you impatiently.
What?
You told me this isn't your domain.
Nonsense.
What?
It's the fruit of your hard labor.
Can't you see how everyone enjoys their time here?
I'm a great time.
They have this newfound home.
Meow meow meow meow.
Some of them might look a little lost.
I concur.
But what of it?
They have a place to be for all of eternity.
Oh, yeah.
I took my kids and my wife to heaven.
The dead will whisper.
Yeah, yeah.
And I will be there with them.
Because I've done good deeds.
Yeah.
Have a look at your masterpiece.
I raptured them myself.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, our masterpiece.
Oh, yippee.
Oh, so I get to...
You're an artiste.
Go up the long, long...
Can you run up these?
Or...
No.
This is me running.
Okay.
Oh, so like...
I have to go look through each window?
No?
Oh, I just have to go up.
Might be a...
Might be a lengthy journey.
Oh my god.
Gotta get my cardio up.
Yeah.
Have you ever been up a lighthouse before?
No, I haven't.
Have you?
Me?
No.
Oh.
The only thing I know about lighthouses is from the...
Uh...
What's his name?
Um...
The spiral man.
You know that guy, the writer?
Uzumaki?
Uzumaki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the only thing I know about lighthouses.
Oh.
It can kill.
Oh, I'm up here.
Oh, there's lots of candles.
I can't go crazy now.
Go grab one.
Grab one.
No.
Oh, there's another candle.
Is that my beautiful wife that I killed?
Oh, my God.
Hello, my beautiful wife.
Where's the beer can?
Yeah, we're...
Oh, look.
It's so romantic.
It gave us romantic music along the line.
Whoa.
It's not a scary game anymore.
I think it's supposed to be more somber.
Like...
Oh, that's my wife.
She was so beautiful.
I killed her.
I'll see her in heaven, doll.
No.
I'm gonna go to heaven, guys.
Cats have nine lives.
What's this?
All cats go to heaven.
Yeah.
Stress build.
What's that?
Prevents.
Prevents stress build.
Oh, prevent stress.
Oh, my God.
There's my address, guys.
Oh.
Don't go to our house.
And definitely don't report us to the police.
Oh, my God.
I didn't do anything bad.
Explain this to me.
Oh.
Oh, there's my wife.
Please talk to me.
Hello.
What do you mean explain?
I wanna help you.
We're on meds because we have stress.
Oh, I'm mixing...
Oh, I'm mixing alcohol and meds.
Oh.
Wait, she doesn't know who prescribed us the medicine?
Oh, it's like when people take, like, Adderall.
Like, you know how, like, they just be like, um...
Uh, I don't know what excuse they make, but that's how, like, people get free Adderall.
Which is illegal, guys.
Which is ill- I shouldn't tell you guys how.
That's illegal.
Oh?
Oh, Dwayne.
I don't think you're helping.
Why?
Yeah, you're making me sad.
Aw.
You're making me sad.
Oh, it's the plague doctor!
It's probably blood money, but I don't care.
Wait, I have money?
Oh, we're rich?
Yeah, I was gonna say!
Oh, yeah!
What, you married me for my money?
Do you want me to kick the bucket?
I did not look like I had money.
Like...
I mean, have you seen this place, though?
This house is humongous.
Yeah, but then it's the suburbs, where you can't...
Like, he could've bought this house, like, 20 years ago.
Back when houses weren't that expensive.
Or he could've, like, inherited it from his, like, dead parents.
Horrifying.
You should die.
I mean, it's just something.
Claire, you're not helping very much.
Yeah, you're not helping my depression, Claire.
This is why I killed you.
Kill yourself by yourself alone.
And die!
What?
I thought we're gonna...
Whoa!
Yippee!
Yay!
Oh no, I remember the...
The spiral hallway.
New ride!
New Six Flags ride!
That one was pretty long.
Yeah, that one was a long chapter.
Hey, that was four.
You're right, guys.
I got four.
Oh yeah, one left.
Pride.
Oh, please.
It didn't...
Your game...
It's alive, right?
Where am I?
I don't know.
Oh.
Okay, it's alive.
Oh, I'm just in the...
Oh, okay.
I was like, where am I?
Alright, one more.
Okay, nice!
Now, just the one by the front door.
Okay, we gotta go back upstairs, though.
Yeah.
Why do we always end up in this area?
It's our little...
It's our chair room.
Oh my gosh, we're so close to finishing this, you guys.
Guys, I knew saving that one area for last was a good idea.
It is so convenient.
Right here.
There you go.
What is this?
Okay, but where do we...
Wake up.
Where do we do with this one, though?
Where do we go?
In the garage.
Oh, it's in the garage?
Yes.
Oh, wait.
It's our favorite place.
Wait, it stopped talking!
Hank!
What's the point?
I think that controls the...
In the garage.
The lights in here.
Oh no, it doesn't...
Oh, actually...
I think...
Wait, where is the...
Thing, though?
Um...
Move up the stairs to the top floor of the garage.
Okay.
There you go.
Now what?
There should be like a tool box or something in here.
Oh, it's right here.
It's a lighter.
Hey guys, I found another lighter!
Yeah, exactly!
A double wielding...
A double wielding lighter?
Uh...
Where is it?
Wait, hold on.
Um...
Before going through the door at the top of the stairs, move into the space beside the door.
Past the...
Past...
The stacked boxes and suitcases.
Like this?
I mean...
There's a tall red tool box against the wall.
That one.
No?
Grab the tool box and move it to the left.
Oh!
What?
It's so hard to move this slow.
Oh, it's so slow!
Yeah, it's so incredibly slow.
I actually have to use my entire mouse pad for this.
Maybe...
Maybe the video showed that.
Because how the hell are you supposed to know otherwise?
Oh, there it is.
I guess that's...
Oh, alright.
Now where?
The...
The Omega...
Verse...
Alpha...
Alpha and Omega.
Alright, now where?
The handle is in...
For the hatch that was shown in the video.
Oh my gosh.
It literally says that in the guide.
It doesn't...
So we have to go watch the video.
Oh my god.
Where is the handle?
Where is the...
You have the handle.
We have to go find the hatch.
Yeah, where is the hatch?
But where is the hatch?
The guide is like, I'm not gonna handle it all the time.
I don't care.
It's...
I don't know.
Basement mannequin?
Someone says basement mannequin.
Oh, okay.
We can try it.
The basement.
It's always in the basement.
When is it not in the basement?
The basement.
Everything is in the basement!
There?
By the mannequin over there.
Check on the floor.
Alright, I'm checking.
Maybe we...
Walked over it before and we never even realized.
Oh, that's true.
Here?
By the mannequin.
No?
Nothing here.
Uh, is it in between like these sheets or anything?
Oh, there it is.
Ah-ha!
Whoops.
Oh, oops.
Ah-ha!
I'm in the cutscene!
What do you want me to do?
It's literally...
Wow!
Yeah, they're like, avoid standing in the dark.
I'm like, in the cutscene, like...
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Before you go in...
It says there's a...
You're on a timer as soon as you enter the room below.
Okay.
It will start...
Slowly start to fill with gas.
You must quickly perform the required objective before gas fills the room or Dwayne will die.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding?
What do I have to...
You'll see an exit doorway ahead of you.
Yes.
Look to the right and get up on the counter.
Okay.
In that direction.
Grab a stool and break the window.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Break the window.
Oh my god.
I wonder if...
I can't tell if that's the...
The end of...
If you'll die or not now.
What do I do?
Um...
I don't know.
Look around.
Oh, there's the gas.
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh.
You need that.
Can you break this again?
Okay.
Maybe you can...
Can you open it?
Oh.
Exit the room by stepping back through the window.
Okay.
Let me...
Get up!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna...
Okay.
To the exit.
Oh...
Okay.
Um...
Yes?
What's the next stat?
I could probably use the axe.
I'm literally looking at the axe right now, holding my axe.
Like, I don't know what... Hold on, I'm reading, I'm reading.
Walk through the wall with the damaged tiles across from the win- across from the counter with- with the window you broke.
Okay.
Oh, I see it right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Seriously?
Okay, that was not the door I was apparently- How would I- How would I figured this out?
Why would they tell you to get an axe?
Why would they tell you to get an axe for the door and then have you not use it?
You know what, you could probably use your axe for that, okay.
Oh, yeah, you- you need the lighter.
Yep, yep.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Why would I use the lighter when the room is gassed up?
Yeah, that too!
I'm just thinking.
Do I not have this- Oh, that's when you know it's all in my head, because there's no fucking explosions from that.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
What the- Oh!
What was that?
I don't know.
What's happening?
My game is tripping out.
That was so incomprehensible!
Yeah, I just like, where did I go?
Why would they tell you you need an axe for the door?
And then you don't use the axe on the door?
And then they're like, you could probably use your axe for this.
What?
It's a- it's merely a justy suggestion, guys!
Am I going the right way?
Uh, probably.
Oh wait, there it is.
There's the tunnel.
Okay.
Freedom!
Are we going back to the- Well, I thought we were going back to the playground for some reason.
Oh, they said probably.
You're right.
Probably, yes.
Oh.
No, they should not even have that.
As a thing.
That is so misleading.
Oh, there's tower footprints.
I don't like that.
Uh-oh.
Maybe it leads to the piece of the- The mask.
Where?
Keep following.
Follow the footprints.
Where does that footprints tell me to go?
Keep following.
Hello?
I guess- Are we going back to literally where we?
No, it goes this way.
Oh!
It just stops?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, you put it in the secret stash.
Yoink!
Okay, is that all of them?
I think we got all of them.
Yeah, we found the pieces!
Now what do we do?
Oh my god.
Can we go back to the progress room with it?
Yep.
Yeah, just go back to the progress.
Uh, this way is faster.
Oh my god, I can see the light.
I can see the light, guys.
Follow the light.
We're almost there.
Final boss time, yeah.
Oh my god.
Just follow the light.
The tar man cometh.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Tartman!
Champion of the tar.
Alright, put on the mask.
They don't know who you are until you put on the mask.
Until you can't have the mask, yeah.
Do you know Dream's a VTuber now?
Yeah, he became a VTuber.
He did a VTuber debut and everything.
What was the point of his... everything that happened?
He can move his hands, too.
He can.
Yeah, what's the point of a face reveal?
He just becomes a VTuber.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, put on the mask!
Put it on!
Here it is.
Now I'm Dream.
But with less of the controversies.
Okay, I hate to tell you something.
What?
We gotta go back to the basement.
I CAN'T FLOW FIGHT!
WHEN DO I LEAVE THE BASEMENT?!
Why is it?
Oh wait, look, everything's good now.
Okay.
Oh, then we're fine.
Yay!
No consequences.
No, we're good then.
We're fine.
Back to the basement.
There we go.
It's like my second home.
It's daddy's basement.
Don't go in there, Lucy.
Back to the basement.
Yes, put on our basement, Uncle.
All good things happen in our basement.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, just follow the open doors.
And...
Here?
Hold on.
Uh...
Wait, what?
Here we go.
Okay, go down the stairs and swing a left.
Then move around the bottom of the stairs.
What does that mean?
Here.
Swing a left.
Can we go to this?
Just pass the next door.
Destroy the wall to the left.
Oh, it's this wall.
This wall.
Okay, we've already gone through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We did that.
That's where, like, the Russian roulette, but with all the bullets.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
So there's no roulette.
It's just...
So there's no Russian.
It's just roulette.
Okay.
This is it.
Oh, my God!
The light!
Ah!
Flashbang!
This was...
Yeah, this is where the gun was.
Yeah.
That's right.
What happened?
We should've...
You should've done that.
I should've done that.
Where are we?
Are we in heaven?
Oh, my God!
I'm in heaven!
See, guys?
No.
Are you kidding me?
I committed.
I went to confession.
He doesn't earn this.
And then the Lord was like, you are forgiven.
And then I'm in heaven.
Oh, my God!
This game just lagged everything.
I'm lagging so hard!
The credit scene has, like, so...
Oh, my God!
Oh,
my God!
Is that really the ending that we got after all of that?
That's it.
That was what everybody wanted to see?
That was the happy ending.
That was it?
Okay, that ending sucked, not gonna lie.
I...
You are forgiven.
What?
What was the...
So, we faced everything?
We, like, acknowledged everything, I guess?
And then everything was fine?
I realized I was an alcoholic and also maybe too into, like, my prescription pills.
And then I went to confessional and then the priest was like, you are forgiven.
And then I went to heaven.
So, it didn't matter that I shot my entire family.
I guess...
And my family forgave me, too.
Like...
I don't know why my family forgave me, but okay.
Never punished.
Oh, my God.
Alright, cool.
Yeah, maybe there's something after this.
No, I think that's it.
Maybe there's a post-credits.
What would the post-credits be?
They send me back to Earth.
I don't know!
They're like, you were there.
What are you saying?
You have, like, unsolved, like, actions in there.
We're sending you...
You have not been forgiven.
We checked through our...
We checked through our books and we realized you forgot one thing.
Oh, yeah, we did it, man!
Yippee!
Woohoo!
We did it!
I don't know how we would have done the last two chapters without the guy.
That was...
A lot of those were like, where do we go?
Like...
Yeah.
It was...
It's using your brain, but too much of what I've...
Too much to what I think we would be able to.
Yeah.
I have an excuse.
I'm sick right now.
That's...
Me too.
I'm sick in the head.
Yeah, yeah.
We didn't take any pills today.
The pills didn't work.
They never work.
That box puzzle?
I don't remember what the box puzzle was.
I...
I don't even remember.
Box puzzle.
All the puzzles has blurred between my mind.
The grandma puzzle was fucking rough.
I would say the grandma chapter was bullshit.
That...
Yeah, that one was tough.
That one.
Thank you for playing.
Yay!
We did it!
Our...
Our journey's over.
That was it!
I was gonna say the last chapter was definitely anti-climatic.
I...
Yeah, I feel like we should have ended on the...
On the picture frame one.
That one was like...
I kind of like...
It felt like a conclusion.
Yeah, that one felt more of a conclusion than the...
I just got forgiven and went to heaven to see my family.
I feel so...
Yeah.
I feel so unfulfilled.
Like...
I'd like...
Yeah.
That did not feel very fulfilling.
We should have went...
We should have went downstairs and just...
Did Russian Roulette with six bullets.
We can...
We always can.
You can load the game.
Yeah.
You can reload the game.
We finished the game.
That was fun.
Just load a save and go down there before the mask.
All right.
Okay.
Let's go.
All right.
We'll do one...
Wait, can you do that?
What's it continue?
I'm pretty sure, right?
That's New Game Plus.
We're at New Game Plus now.
Let's see.
Let's see where it takes us.
That's the Russian Roulette ending.
All right.
Where does it take me?
Wait, do you have...
You don't have the mask on, do you?
I don't know.
No, I don't.
Where is the area?
Oh, it's right...
Here?
Uh...
Yeah, you go through the wall.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the mask ending would have given me like the...
Russian Roulette!
Woo!
Six Flags opened another new ride!
Do you think I'm gonna hit it?
No.
No, I like my odds.
It's all blanks.
It's a blanks.
I like my odds.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, just shoot it!
They announced they are closing a park?
Wait, what?
Oh, Persona!
Yeah, Persona!
Oh, hey, I'm back here.
Wait, where am I?
Well, you got an achievement for that.
Yeah, I did.
Nice.
I Persona'd all over the floor.
Is this, is this Persona?
Oh my god, you're like hobbling over.
Oh my god, I'm hobbling.
Yeah.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm in the progress room.
Oh, hey, look at that.
There, it's like, oh, it's like a speedrun strat!
I don't know if that is.
Look, I spin.
It's just, I don't have to climb up the stairs, guys.
I spin run.
Nice.
What was up with the tar monster?
I think the tar man was supposed to come out of the walls, but then we like...
He never did.
He never, we didn't get crazy enough.
I think so, yeah.
To like let him come out.
Oh, that was fun, guys.
The four-week arc is over, everyone.
We, we went through so much together.
Me and Mint and Whisp and Dragoons.
Oh, look, see?
I knew it.
Look at the poll, Mint.
Look at the poll.
Look at how many percentage it is on.
I closed out of it.
And look how many people voted!
Like...
I knew it!
But, that was, that was a journey, Mint.
What was your favorite part from the entire series?
Um... Russian Roulette.
Because it ended.
It ended in a game.
I also liked going down the twisty hallway.
Oh, yeah.
I liked that, too.
That one was my favorite part.
No, you know what my favorite part was?
The never-ending car honk.
Apparently, I could have turned it off at any time.
Yeah, I know.
I forgot.
I know you could have.
Yeah, yeah, you could have.
But it gave us more, like, it was more atmospheric, you know?
It immersed us more.
Hey, I felt more safe with the car honking.
Like, I think that's why, because apparently the husband was supposed to chase us, also, when we found him.
But, like, he never did.
And I think it's because he was scared of the car honks.
No, he did chase us a couple times.
No!
No, he didn't.
He never chased us.
We saw him one time to activate him being, like, an enemy.
But, like, we never saw him.
We just saw the granny.
Yeah, he never chased us.
Oh.
Yeah.
No, I swear there was one time he did chase us.
No, that one time was when I was like, he's friendly, and then he shanked me.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's like, I'm not friendly.
Friend or foe.
Always foe.
It's crazy.
A man holding, like, a bunch of knives could be, like, an enemy.
Who would have thought?
No.
Could never think about that.
Yeah, I thought...
He was friend-shaped, you know?
He was...
The dad bod makes him friend-shaped.
He was a dad.
What could go wrong?
Yeah, we got hunted by the granny.
We got hunted by Lucy.
Yeah, and his...
And her...
And her demon.
That...
That other...
Remember the demon guy?
That was like...
Oh, yeah, yeah, that guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got hunted by that guy.
He was so inconsequential.
And then the tar man.
Tar man.
Oh!
Yeah, that was fun.
I had a great time.
Finally finishing Visage.
A game that I could never finish for the last four to five years.
But we finally did it.
Finally.
Finally did it.
We did it.
Off the check mark.
Yay!
I also finished the game.
Yeah!
So Min never has to play this game.
Since she technically played it.
After all these years.
I did.
I always think the scariest games out there is...
Was it Layers of Fear?
And...
Actually, no.
Layers of Fear is goofy, though.
Isn't it?
I was gonna say, Layers of Fear is goofy.
Layers of Fear is very goofy as hell.
I always said, Mortary Assistant and Visage and PT are known as the scariest games, right?
Yeah.
Oh, I think a lot of people say, like, this is the scariest game.
I think, yeah.
Visage would be really...
I think it's just because it's like a longer PT, but...
Yeah.
I think the scariest...
I think the scariest chapter was Lucy and the grandma.
The other two were, like, just...
Well, I mean, the other two was, like, a guy in, like...
In...
What were they called?
The crutches chasing us.
That's not really that scary.
Yeah.
To be fair.
I was...
He was fast, though.
He was fast, but, like, it wasn't, like...
That's scary because, like, he kept bugging out, too.
Yeah.
That's why we could, like, literally...
If he lost track of us, he would just walk into a wall.
He just walked into a wall.
But that wasn't that scary.
And then, I guess Tar Man was scary because, like, the way he just looked at us.
Like, his eyes.
But, like, we didn't encounter him that much.
And then, grannies are always scary because it's, like...
Like, you know, you don't know what they'll do.
Yeah.
I think you don't know what's on their minds.
They could be naked.
Most likely.
Probability-wise, an old granny would be naked because they have nothing to hide.
Would be naked.
Yeah.
But...
They're very scary.
But, yeah, that was fun.
I had a great time.
I'm glad Mint was here to play with me and keep me company throughout this because I was never going to finish this game solo.
That's for sure.
When was this game released?
A long time ago.
It was after PT.
Yeah.
That's what I remembered.
Oh, it was in October of 2020.
Oh, it wasn't even that old.
Omar, did you hear that?
Oh, wait.
Uh, wait.
I guess the initial date was 2018.
Oh, the early access.
Yeah, because the initial game only had Lucy.
And then, they added more chapters over the time.
Okay, okay.
Over the time.
Uh, I also heard like...
Did you hear the new Silent Hill game?
That looks so good.
Yeah!
Yeah, the one that's set in Japan.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
I'm not going to be playing it, but...
Really?
I'm not playing that game on release.
Did you like...
Did you like 2?
I...
That game actually scared me so much that I had like...
My heart actually like was beating really fast every time I streamed it.
And I was actually getting like goosebumps too when I was playing it.
And I could only play it maximum like 2 hours.
Because I would get too scared.
Like, I actually legitimately was so scared that I could only play 2 hours max each time.
Like, I'm really bad with horror.
I saw someone say that they have zero trust in the game.
But seriously, it's written by like Ryukishi7.
That guy is...
His brain is like insane.
I have only the highest hopes for it.
I don't know why.
What did he do before?
He's written like Higurashi and Umineko.
Oh!
Yeah.
Wait, is it Umineko?
What's Umineko?
I know the other one.
It's...
It's another...
It's like a murder...
Oh God.
How do you describe Umineko?
Uh...
It's...
It's like a mind...
Fuckery...
Everything.
Yeah, I never heard of it.
I know the other one.
The...
The Higurashi is the...
The village, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The village where like things keep happening.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and they did like 300,000 like re...
Like re-releases of him.
Of that show.
Because it's so good.
It's really good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I heard of that one.
Uh...
But yeah, why...
Wait, why do people think it's not gonna be good?
I think because, you know, Konami has been a little, you know, iffy with their games.
Yeah, but who...
Which...
What company?
What dev...
Is it like...
The dev focused fully in Konami?
Or is it...
Uh...
Oh, I don't know actually who's developing it.
Because like Silent Hill 2 was developed by the Lairs of Fear people.
Yeah, Bloober Team.
Yeah, but they did really good though.
The re...
The...
That's what I heard.
That's the only reason I hadn't played it.
Because like...
No, it's actually...
It's really...
I did hear that.
But...
So...
Yeah.
Yeah, but the...
It was really, really good.
Like I was actually really, really fucking scared.
Um...
But also, I'm...
I get scared really easily.
So you might actually not get that scared.
Uh...
But for me like...
The...
I think the remake was really good.
Uh...
But...
Other than that...
Yeah, I'm looking forward to the new Silent Hill.
The trailer looks really nice.
I know.
But we haven't gotten a gameplay trailer though.
That's the problem.
I know.
I still...
I don't know.
I still think it'll be okay.
Yeah, what is it coming out?
I don't know.
Uh...
What is it?
Silent Hill F?
Uh...
I don't think there's a release date yet.
I remember it's...
It's on Steam.
Let me see.
I saw it like...
It was like soon-ish, yeah?
No date yet?
May 26th.
So I was like...
This month!
It looks like Fatal Frame, Silent Hill.
I'm just so excited.
Have you played Fatal Frame yet on stream?
Not on stream.
Why haven't you played Fatal Frame?
I know that's a game you've always wanted to play on stream.
I know.
Those games scare the heck out of me though.
Oh...
I mean, I could be there.
Actually...
They're long.
They're way longer than this.
Oh, wait.
How long?
They're like...
Because they're like JRPG.
Well, not RPG, you know.
But like they're...
You know...
They're long.
Which is the shortest Fatal Frame?
The best one would be to do two...
I don't know.
I like five also.
Fatal Frame 2.
How long to be?
Let's see.
Okay.
Oh.
Well, this is the main story.
This is about like 10 to 14 hours.
That's not too bad.
I mean, this was a four-parter.
And we did like three...
Two to three hours.
How long to be Visage?
How...
What are people's averages?
Okay, but...
Nine hours?
Okay.
Yeah, it's like similar.
It's just a four-parter.
I'm down for it.
If you ever want to do Fatal Frame on stream and you need someone to be there.
Okay.
I'll...
Reach out then.
Someone was like...
No.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, yeah.
And I did stall...
Oh, wait.
You're right.
I did stall a lot.
That's why it's four-parter.
But I completed every chapter per stream, guys.
I...
I still completed a chapter each time.
Even with the stalling.
Um...
Uh...
But...
Yeah.
Wait, which Fatal Frame are you planning on doing?
That's the one of the cameras, right?
That's why it's...
Three, two.
Two?
Yeah, the ones with the cameras.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Those are freaky.
I remember they're being freaky.
Yeah, they're freaky.
Yeah.
They're spooky scary.
Spooky scary.
Oh.
All right, yeah.
Well, yeah.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, everybody, for...
Yeah!
For hanging out with us.
We completed another game.
Both Min and I.
Min never has to touch Visage on her channel.
Woohoo!
Yay!
I'm free!
She's free from Visage!
Yeah.
But thank you, Min, for hanging out with me.
For doing this charity goal with me.
I really appreciate it.
Yep.
And for being my great guide.
That was very helpful throughout it.
She was so helpful, guys.
I never...
One guide or misled ever once.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a one guy on my shoulder.
No.
You guys need to learn from me.
But...
You need to re-watch this thing.
You need to learn how to be a good backseater like Min.
It's not like we were stuck in the fucking electrical room for 15 minutes because we forgot.
That was not my fault.
No, no, no.
It was both our faults because you also were there when I picked out that painting.
I didn't hear this.
When we were arguing, you were there as well when we picked up that painting.
When we first found the electrical room and I was like, what's this painting?
This is victim-blaming.
No, you're victim-blaming.
Me.
Someone should click the moment when we first found that painting.
and then just to propose that and then cut to the part where were trying to...
But we were in the breaker room arguing about where that painting is.
I wanted to see like, when.
I was probably reading the guide while you picked it up, but I didn't even see.
I want to see like- like where we were at when we first found that painting.
And it cut to like when we started arguing.
I think I was reading the guide while you picked it up.
I'm just saying.
I think it was before we were reading guides.
What do you mean?
I think it was before the guide itself.
I'm a guide.
We were like, why is Lucy taking away all these lights?
What's the point of flicking them on?
Actually, I don't remember.
I think that was on... No, we were on the Grammy chapter.
No, we were at the... We couldn't have been at the Grammy chapter.
I don't know.
You only get these once you start watching the day.
I don't know which chapter we were in when we got to the birth breaker.
I don't know.
We'll find out.
We'll find out when they make the clip.
Then we'll know what chapter we were in.
Which stream it was.
Thank you, everybody, guys.
Is there any final words you want to make, Mint, before we end the stream?
Nah, I'm good.
Oh, okay.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture, check in, move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for us, head to bed.
Yes, you deserve it.
Oh, yeah, Mint, you had a long day today.
You did a four-hour stream, and then you did another three-hour here.
I know.
You must be tired.
Yeah, all right, guys.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.